Ich hoffe, es geht wieder.
Test, Test.
Und wieder?
Okay, keine Ahnung, was da wieder los ist.
I don't know.
OBS abgeschissen.
Hatte ich auch noch nicht.
Wusste gar nicht, dass OBS abstürzen kann.
Ich bin verreckt, weil ich in OBS geguckt habe.
Jetzt habe ich keine Buffs mehr.
Kein Vodafone.
Ich glaube, da kann Vodafone gar nicht so viel für.
Diesmal.
Ich muss noch was futtern nebenbei, Leute.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich habe vor sechs Stunden oder so angefangen zu streamen.
Da ist Neko, oder?
Nee, boah.
Geiler.
Schock.
Ich habe vor sechs Stunden angefangen zu streamen.
Und habe seitdem nichts gesnackt.
Also es ist echt Zeit.
Ja, Leute, wenn der Kreisel-Crying läuft, ist es vorbei.
Wenn der Kreisel-Crying läuft, dann kenne ich nichts.
Was? Griechischer Rage?
Du meinst unseren BG-Leader, den Griechen, ja.
Der ist auch wieder am Start.
Aber nachdem ich zuerst Alp gelevelt habe und jetzt mitlevel,
ist das Ding halt, ich kann auch nicht mit,
aber ich würde halt, also das ist eh immer der Beste,
wenn er ausrastet.
Das ist immer der Beste, ey.
Das ist immer der Beste.
Haha.
Muss ich ja, muss ich routen.
Oh, man sieht halt nichts.
Es sind so viele fucking Bäume hier, Mann.
Alter.
Da geh ich auf Tannenwald so.
Es ist ja nichts zu sehen, ey.
It's neutral.
Haben wir sie jetzt alle eingesammelt?
Nee, oder?
Okay, jetzt haben wir sie alle eingesammelt.
Alter, was ein Akt, Mann.
Was wir hier durch sind.
So, wo müssen wir denn jetzt, wo müssen wir jetzt kurz hin?
Lass mal kurz Quest-Stelz.
Äh.
Hier, hier gedrahen müssen wir.
Ah, Channels sind auf.
Welche und Odin sind nichts.
Jetzt dahin, würde ich sagen.
Ey, ohne Mist.
Ich, ich hatte eigentlich vor, im Dezember viele Videos zu machen.
Das Ding ist, meine Katz ist krank und irgendwie ist es mir jetzt nicht so.
Kann ich Videos aufnehmen?
Teil das Ding.
Jetzt gehen wir erstmal Quests abgeben.
Wow.
Ich umlaufe das mal schnell hier.
Gut.
Oh, Quests abgeben.
Wir dürfen noch nicht ganz 31 sein, aber es sollte auf jeden Fall in die Richtung gehen.
Also, ihr, ihr seht's, Frontier-Quests sind wirklich sehr, sehr zackig.
So, Exp.
Finish.
Oh doch, wir sind 31.
Bam, easy.
Okay, wir gehen.
Andere Grenzfestung porten wir.
Äh, gibt's hier irgendwie nen Buff, Buff?
Ähm.
Gibt's hier irgendeinen Buff-Typ?
Buff, Buff.
Stellst' am Start?
Nee.
Ähh.
Hau mal hier.
Oh Leute.
Ich bin braindead.
Wo ist denn ihr denn?
Ah wo ist der Buff-Typ?
Ich war lange nicht in der Midgard.
Hier, Shaman.
Okay.
Let's go!
Aber was brauchen wir denn hier jetzt noch?
Primo's Pride, V alien.
Okay.
Coldfeed und Argour brauchen wir.
bestellen ich muss mal ich muss mal schauen ob es nicht schon updates für
das ui gibt wo die wo die mobs auf der map draufstehen
es wäre enorm praktisch ich muss mal kurz schauen also wir müssen diese dann
müssen wir vorerst pike killen rainbow sprites und das war's das war's
da gibt schon wieder level für alle leute die frontier quest geben aber
richtig krass exp hätte ich das gewusst ich hätte nur frontier quest gemacht
man das geht ja richtig gut abkommen wir sind schon ein 30,3 also wenn ich so
weitermache wer das hat mit 40 was ich wusste wieder trainen waffe ist lila
gegner mit zum glück können auch irgendwelche alps sein ich hoffe der
tauntet und blockt
nice zu ordentlich da mage reinfahren
wo sind wir eigentlich vorhin stehen geblieben wollte ich euch noch nicht
nicht noch die restlichen klassen erklärt doch wollte ich eigentlich genau
wir sind bei hip klassen stehen geblieben die klassen wo ich am wenigsten
ahnung von habe weil ich bis auf kurze zeit war so ein halbes dreiviertel jahr
und danach noch mal wie so ein halbes jahr nie wirklich viel
gespielt habe also insofern aber ich meine ich kenne natürlich die hip
klassen und weiß so wie was gespielt wird beziehungsweise was was macht ich
muss aber sagen es ist für mich persönlich der und attraktivste realm
früher übrigens als op so verschrien aber es ist vielleicht am angenehmsten
sich anzugucken weil alles schön grünes aber ich mag die klassen in hip echt am
wenigsten weiß nicht wie es nicht so leuten geht die selbst da auch gespielt
spielt haben und hier sind. Ich weiß, viele
lieben Hip und spielen
nix anderes. Und die haben
wahrscheinlich auch den aktivsten BG-Leader für
RVR. Kannst mit Pilz von morgens bis abends
rumzergen. Ja, aber
trotzdem, also es gibt in Hip
nicht viele Klassen, auf die ich persönlich Bock habe.
Also ich hab mal ne Zeit lang Bade gespielt, der Fabian übrigens
auch. Und Druide?
Druide gefällt mir eigentlich noch am besten in Hip.
Aber auf dauerhaft
Main-Support
und also als einzigen Char
hätt ich keinen Bock. Hab ich lange genug gemacht.
Und Argur,
den müssen wir bashen.
Argur.
Deswegen level ich ja auch
Alp und mit. Hip werde ich mir wahrscheinlich
nix leveln. Auf Hip hab ich keinen Bock.
Also nix
Hip-Hip-Hurra hier.
Hip mag ich nicht.
Aber von hinten drauf,
da kann er nicht blocken.
Damn.
Easy.
Oh.
Ne. Dachte grad irgendwie,
das ist ein Gegner.
Brain. Brain.
Lag.
Spike. Rainbow Sprite.
Ne, gibt's hier alles nicht.
Da unten gibt's was an Avacryl.
Was
macht der jetzt?
So.
Tja. Ich versuche mal was mit dem Midgard über die
Hip-Klassen zu erzählen. Okay.
Geht mit der größten
Nervabfahrklasse im ganzen Spiel
los. Animist.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine Klasse,
die mehr gehasst ist
in diesem Spiel.
Als Anni.
Animist können so komische
Pilzpets beschwören,
die durch alles und jenes durchglitschen
und einfach nur abfacken und nerven.
Niemand mag Animisten.
Außer Animistenspieler.
Nicht mal Hips mögen Annis.
Also wenn ihr die Klasse
mit dem höchsten Abfackpotenzial
spielen wollt, dann ist es
eindeutig Animister.
Falls ihr heute mal irgendwo
im BG oder im RVR-Gebiet hier so Pilze
habt rumstehen sehen, so kleine graue
Pilze, das sind Anni-Pets.
Das ist einfach
ultra nervig, Mann.
Ansonsten kann ich zu der Klasse nicht viel
sagen. Außer, dass sie
manchmal tatsächlich auch
ähm, ach guck mal,
hier gibt's, ah, hier gibt's Fische.
Tatsächlich manchmal auch in Gruppen
gespielt wird, weil
sie ganz gut Burst-Damage
machen kann mit Nuke
plus Lifetap und
der Root-Pilz auch nervig
ist. Aber ansonsten ist Anni echt nicht so dabei.
Wahnsinn. Also ich
persönlich mag Anni-Mist überhaupt gar nicht.
Aber, tja, vielleicht
vielleicht, oh, Dark-Schwimm-Physics,
Mann. Aber ich
mein, ich bin auch kein hauptsächlicher
Hip-Spieler. Vielleicht, ja,
wird man das dann anders sehen. Aber Anni ist echt
nicht so. Ich find, Anni-Mist ist echt
eine Klasse, die das Game nicht gebraucht hätte.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Banshee. Banshee ist eine wirklich
coole Klasse, die
leider nicht so richtig
nach dem Start vom Addon ihre Nischen, ihre
Nischenplatz gefunden hat.
Eigentlich ist Banshee eine richtig coole
Klasse. Macht AE-Schaden
allerdings nicht
in
Radius-Form, sondern in
ja, Cone-Form.
Also eigentlich eine richtig
gute AE-Farm-Klasse.
Die wurden ein paar Mal genervt
und danach hat irgendwie nie wieder einer Banshee gespielt.
Wie
Banshee auf Eden ist,
weiß ich nicht.
Ob's da irgendwelche Custom-Patches gab.
Also, es fangen jetzt mit zwei doofen Klassen an.
Hat das jetzt angefangen, die Liste in HIP.
Als nächstes haben wir Bade.
Okay, Bade ist
eines der besten Support-Klassen
im gesamten Spiel.
Ähm, so.
Also, kommen wir mal zum Thema Bade.
Bade ist eines der Support-Klassen
schlechthin in dem Spiel.
Bade hat Speed, Bade hat AE-CC,
Bade hat, der Fisch sieht irgendwie ein bisschen
verpackt aus.
Bade hat Speed, Bade hat AE-CC, Bade hat AE-CC, Bade hat AE-CC.
Bade kann mal wieder fast alles, außer
und sogar gut heilen.
Bade kann eigentlich nur nicht Damage machen.
Und selbst das, zumindest hat Bade
irgendwie einen Melee-Angriff, den er theoretisch
benutzen kann, aber der ist nicht gut.
Also, Bade ist, wenn
einer wirklich so eine
High-Skill,
aber da kommt's auch richtig drauf an,
Support-Klasse spielen will, dann tatsächlich
Bade, wenn er HIP spielen will.
Also, gute Gruppen stehen und
fallen mit dem Bade.
Wenn der Bade gut ist, dann geht's, dann läuft's.
Wenn der Bade suckt, kriegt man nix auf die Reihe.
Und Bade ist halt auch
mega nervig zu spielen, weil du alles irgendwie machen musst.
Mehrere Songs spielen,
CC'en, teilweise
Backup heilen, alles. Und
gleichermaßen wollen dich permanent
alle Gegner killen. Also, Bade
ist echt richtig abfuck.
Ich glaube, eines der skilligsten
Klassen in ganz Dark, würde ich sagen, Bade.
Äh, definitiv. Also,
das ist sowas von
keine Einsteiger-Klasse.
Also, wenn du als Bade
anfängst, Dark zu spielen,
dann hast du...
Wirst du es nicht lang machen, ja.
Oder du wirst...
Du wirst
Instant Pro, so nach dem...
Pro gibt's ja nicht, aber jetzt weiß ich, was ich meine.
Bist du Instant richtig gut oder wirst du rein...
Also, keine gute Einstiegsklasse. Eines der besten Support-Klassen,
die es gibt in diesem Spiel, aber
definitiv keine Einstiegsklasse. Eines der
schwersten Klassen, die es gibt.
Das ist ein kleines Problem, was
HIP hat. Dadurch, dass sie so
es selbst, aber
finde ich auch gar nicht so spaßig,
fehlen immer
in HIP sehr viele Baden.
Also,
HIP hat's mit am schwierigsten,
so ihre Supporter
aufzufüllen.
Druiden gibt's wie Sand am Meer, aber Baden
und vor allem gescheite Baden,
gibt's nicht so viel. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch
berufen fühlt, ist Bade für euch die Klasse,
die ihr auch in HIP spielen wollt. Aber wie gesagt,
Einsteiger-Klasse definitiv nicht.
Blademaster ist quasi der Bersi oder
der Söldner von HIP.
Dual-Wield-Melee-Damage-Klasse.
Ziemlich gut.
Ziemlich ähnlich, aber halt zu Söldner auch.
Wenn auch ein paar Feinheiten, ja.
Tatsächlich würde ich sagen, dass Söldner und
Blademaster noch im gesamten Darog die
ähnlichsten Klassen sind.
Der Rest ist ja wirklich grundsätzlich
unterschiedlich immer.
Ich glaub, wir haben's, ja?
Was war bloß noch?
Oh, bloß noch die Fische.
Och, die Fische, dann haben wir's.
Und dann gibt's Exp.
Fett Exp.
Okay, next.
Oh, Fisch-Bash.
Nächste Klasse, Champion.
Champion ist tatsächlich eine der
unbeliebtesten Klassen im ganzen Darog.
Champion ist von der Idee her cool.
Praktisch findet er aber
so gut wie nie einen Spot.
Weil für BG,
es sei denn, Eden hat super Custom-Anpassungen
für Champion.
Von denen ich nix weiß.
Weil ich mich nicht mit Hip-Klassen
beschäftigt hab auf Eden.
Champion ist eine Klasse,
die ist eigentlich als Debuffer,
als Nahkampf-Debuffer gedacht.
Du hast die besten Debuffs,
Single-Target-Debuffs,
im gesamten Spiel.
Das Problem ist halt,
das bringt nix, weil du nicht in Damage
fährst wie andere Nahkämpfer.
Und Debuffs jetzt nicht so
krass entscheidend sind.
Und Champion ein paar andere Nachteile,
hat die Debuffs nicht aufwiegen.
So, im Endeffekt.
Deswegen selbst die krassen Elite-Gruppen
spielen selten Champion.
Und, also zumindest, wie gesagt,
es sei denn, es gibt irgendwelche
Eden-Anpassungen, von denen ich nix weiß.
Und auch in BGs ist Champion jetzt nicht so beliebt.
Also BG ist quasi zerk PvP.
Also Champion, cool gedacht,
hat es aber nie irgendwie, seit Release war das,
war das mit die unbeliebteste Klasse,
glaube ich, im Game.
Die Fische machen mich fertig,
die reinploppen in die Kamera.
Denke ich immer, das ist ein Gegner.
So, Druide.
Druide ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse,
wenn man Supporter spielen will.
Druide ist easy zu spielen,
hat ein Pet, kann dementsprechend
noch ein bisschen mehr machen,
neben buffen und heilen.
Druide ist quasi wie der Cleric aus Albion,
nur mit einem Pet.
Anstelle, anstelle Blitze.
Ist quasi die Main-Healer, Main-Buffer-Class,
in Hip.
Das heißt, wenn jemand Bock hat,
also ich habe auch, also in der Zeit,
wo ich Hip gespielt habe,
habe ich tatsächlich hauptsächlich
Bade und Druide gespielt.
Wenn einer Bock auf Hip hat,
Support spielen will,
ist wahrscheinlich einstiegsmäßig
Druide die beste Wahl für ihn.
Bin ich überladen oder so?
Warum läuft der schneller?
Oder läuft der gar nicht schneller?
Ey, das täuscht, der läuft nicht schneller.
Sah nur so aus.
So, als nächstes haben wir Eldritch.
Eldritch ist tatsächlich, also man muss sagen,
man erkennt bei den unterschiedlichen Reichen
immer so ein gewisses Thema.
Also Albion ist halt Ritter, König Arthus,
Midgard ist Wikinger, Nahkampf
und Hibernia ist halt Natur und Magie.
Deswegen hat Hibernia auch sehr viel
Magie-thematisch bezogene Caster und Heiler
und sowas in der Richtung.
Sind übrigens auch die einzigen,
die Empathie-Skillen müssen.
Wo ist der Dude hin?
Ach, der ist da.
Ja, der ist da.
Moment, das Keep ist gar nicht uns, wohl.
Okay.
Also Eldritch ist tatsächlich eine interessante Caster.
Eldritch ist so ein bisschen
Mischung aus
DPS-Caster und
so Support-Utility-Caster.
Die meisten,
oh, da ist eine Hexe, da ist eine Hexe, oder?
Oh, eine Lurie, den könnten wir eigentlich,
hätten wir drauf gehen können.
Den hätten wir, hätten wir geschafft.
Das war ein 50er, war ein 50er,
den hätten wir aber gut gespielt, zu zweit gepackt.
Ähm, ja.
Also, Eldritch ist,
hat kein Pet,
Eldritch kann richtig gut Damage machen
und hat
Near-Sight und solche, also ziemlich gute Support-Spells.
Die meisten
Hip-Caster-Gruppen
haben
einen Eldritch dabei.
Und Mentars und sowas, aber
Eldritch ist da meistens dabei
für Support und Damage.
Also wer Bock hat auf nicht
so einen reinen One-Button-Char,
und Caster spielen will in Hip,
der ist mit Eldritch eines ganz gut, ganz gut beliebt.
Außerdem, auch sehr beliebt
in allen möglichen Gruppen, immer.
So, als nächstes Enchanter.
Enchanter ist ein bisschen wie Eldritch,
ohne die Support-Spells, dafür mit Pet.
Also auch richtig, richtig gut Damage.
Debuff
und, ähm,
DPS.
Und hat halt noch ein Pet, was nerven kann.
Spielen auch sehr viele Leute in, ähm,
Battle-Groups
und auch in Achtergruppen und sowas.
Da ist nicht, ist nicht übel.
Wobei man sagen muss, lange Zeit
underrated as fuck,
aber, ich mach das jetzt überspringen,
das jetzt einfach mal, lange Zeit underrated
as fuck und jetzt quasi
Pflicht für jede ernsthafte Hip-Gruppe.
Mentalist.
Weil, dammit,
oh Gott.
Ein Yeti.
Weil, gutes, guten
Damage, äh,
und Support-Spells.
Und Pets.
Also,
wer, wer, wer Bock hat
auf nen Caster mit nem Pet,
der richtig gut
Damage machen kann, aber auch
viele Unterstützung-Skills hat,
für Crew, für den ist Manta nicht schlecht.
Äh, als nächstes kommt
Hero, der heißt in der deutschen Version übrigens
Fian. Ich hab immer noch keinen Plan,
warum man Hero mit Fian
übersetzt hat, aber
so ist es halt.
Haben sie sich damals gedacht, ist ne gute Idee.
Äh, Hero ist quasi der Main-Tank.
Inhip.
Er ist quasi ein bisschen wie, wie Armsman oder Krieger.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass er
sich in nen Elch verwandeln kann und ein bisschen mehr,
bisschen mehr Lebenspunkte kriegt,
aber ansonsten ist es im Prinzip sowas wie
Armsman und, äh, Krieger.
Nur, dass er auch ne
Unique-Waffenlinie bekommt,
so wie Armsman auch, nämlich
nicht wirklich Unique, aber
nahezu Unique, nämlich so
fette, fette, äh,
Hammer kann er hämmern.
Das machen auch viele.
Äh, 50er,
wie heißt das?
Ich hab vergessen, wie das, wie das, wie diese Specs,
Speck-Linie heißt. DW oder, ne, DW
ist vom LW Long-Weapon
oder Large-Weapon.
Also wer Hip spielt
und Main-Tank spielen will, muss Fian
spielen oder Hero spielen.
Nice.
So, die Wahl geht jetzt
auf. Wir sind 42.
Äh, nicht 42,
aber 42 wär ich gern.
Wir sind,
wir sind 32.
Ich kauf mir jetzt endlich Endo-Pots,
Leute.
Ich werd jetzt erst mal Sellen gehen.
So, was haben wir hier?
Können wir ersetzen? Nice.
Wie sonst nix?
Belt.
Können wir ersetzen?
Ring.
Armlinge können wir ersetzen?
Dwarven.
Large Sword. Nice. Können wir ersetzen?
Ah.
Auch bester Skin vom Schwert.
Ähm.
Thrust-Bänder.
Gachi-Bass.
62, 61.
Nope. Okay. Dann sellen wir den Rest mal.
Ctrl-S, Ctrl-S.
S.
Hallo?
Ah, der will das nicht. Okay.
Was haben wir hier an den...
Was hat der hier? Der hat
Heat und Parry. Das ist ja ein Schrott, Alter.
Äh, Magic-Skills.
Parry, Slash.
Den brauchen wir auch nicht. Ähm...
Thrust, Hits, Magic-Skills.
Alter, ist ja nur Schrott dabei. Ich fass nicht.
Richtig, richtig Müll.
Thrust, Hits, Magic-Skills.
Naja.
Kommt besser als ein Parry, wenn du interessiert bist.
Komm, Heat ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ah, komm. Scheiß drauf.
Zack. Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Zack.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Jetzt haben wir auch genug Geld für ordentliche Tränke.
Eis.
Warum hab ich das aufgehoben?
Macht das irgendeinen Sinn?
Hits, Body, All Weapons?
Parry, Decks, All Weapons?
Ja, vielleicht.
Gut. Jetzt potten wir mal in die Housing-Zone
und kaufen uns endlich mal mal gescheite Tränke.
Mana-Tränke und Endu-Tränke.
Ah, wo ist der?
Wo ist der Porter?
Ne, heute kein C++. Ich muss Level 40 werden.
Entrance Housing.
Und ich muss immer noch meinen Brötchen futtern.
Steht hier ewig rum.
Also, Endu-Potions kaufen.
Kostet zwar Kohle.
Schauen wir mal, wo es die billigste gibt.
90?
80?
Ne, Moment, das ist der falsche, ne?
Das ist der mit 30 Charges.
Ich muss nach Crater suchen.
Crater.
Ja, die Dark-Suche sackt halt ein bisschen.
What the fuck?
Except.
Ähm, 90, 100.
100.
99, 100.
59.
98.
Hier.
89.
Ich muss gerade ein bisschen auf meine Kohle gucken.
Ja, zwar.
90, 80.
Ja, gab es einen 80er.
80.
88.
Komm, wir kaufen das 80.
Ich muss ein bisschen auf mein Geld gucken gerade.
Weil ich, da kommt ja auch noch, ähm,
Market Explorer Fee dabei und sowas.
Aber ist das auch das Richtige?
Target regenerates endurance during the duration of the spell.
100 Charges.
Buy.
Yes.
Nice.
Endlich, Endu-Buff, Mann.
Wurde, es wurde auch Zeit.
Xeto!
An das Trinken erinnert.
Moment.
Excellent.
So, und jetzt noch ein Mana-Trank mit ordentlich Charges.
Und dann sind wir ready.
So, Xeto.
Nice.
Du wurdest getimeoutet.
Du hast jetzt bloß ein Problem.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Leute endtimeoutet.
Untimeout.
Grafik ist echt ein Joke.
Warum?
Das ist ein Game von 2001.
Was erwartest du?
Okay, Strong Draught of Power.
Das brauchen wir.
49.
Ja, 49 ist gut.
30 Charges.
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Ah, 10 Charges.
30 Charges Mana.
Okay.
Brauche ich mir zwei Tränke.
Und dann ist mein Geld all.
Perfekt.
GG.
Ah, shit.
Das kann ich noch gar nicht nehmen.
Ich kack Noob.
Egal.
Mit 40 brauche ich es dann.
Aber ein 30er End-Noob-Trank kann ich nehmen.
Okay.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Wir sind früher oder später 40.
Gut.
Weiter geht's.
Was für ein BG gibt es denn mit 32?
Lass uns nochmal kurz reinchecken.
Abchecken.
Nee, Entrance.
Da bin ich doch gerade schon.
Lul.
Lass uns nochmal kurz in die Battlegrounds gucken.
Was ist denn mit 32?
Ist das ein Mollwig?
Mollwig?
Kann das sein?
32?
Mollwig?
Äh.
Game?
Hallo?
Nee, Wilton, nicht Mollwig.
Erstmal die ganzen...
Quests annehmen.
Rot-Kill.
Genau wieder am Start.
Kenn ich auch von Season 1.
Aber wir sind 32.
Da können wir einmal trainieren und...
Es gibt, glaube ich, beim nächsten Level...
Ah ja.
Nächstes Level gibt es neuen Speed.
Nice.
Was haben wir hier?
Endu.
Red Stings.
Äh.
Riot Plastic.
Ah.
Es gibt endlich den Shield-Song.
Sehr schön.
Den müssen wir gleich auf die...
Leiste legen.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, welchen Matze ich immer verwende.
Was mein Hotkey drauf ist.
Ähm.
So.
Song.
Ich weiß, der replaced das automatisch, aber es dauert immer eine Weile.
Okay.
Endu.
Äh.
Nicht Endu.
Resi-Song.
Endu.
Okay.
Nächstes Level gibt es neuen Speed.
Den brauche ich auf jeden Fall noch.
So.
Hier ist aber nicht viel los in Wilton, hä?
Wilton.
22 Leute.
Doch.
Ist ein bisschen was los.
Ich stelle es mal hinterher.
Da kommt jetzt der Rotkehlchen her.
Und jetzt mit Endu-Potz.
Die hat keinen Bock, dass ich hinterher laufe.
Okay.
Dann nicht.
Ah.
Nee.
Da ist eine Group.
Hinter der Group werde ich hergruben.
Wäre die können...
Die können mich auch ihn weiten.
Wäre auch okay.
Ah.
Ich stelle es mal der Group hinterher.
Da können...
Die könnten mich auch einfach hinweiten.
Ja.
Siehst du?
Nice.
Let's go.
Ah ja.
In Daight sind's Gruppen übrigens.
Ach.
Achtergruppen, nicht wie in World of Warcraft
oder Final Fantasy oder so.
Hundertgruppen, das sind
Achtergruppen. Bietet sehr viel
Variationsmöglichkeiten.
Der Ingame-Chat.
Ich bepeger gerade.
Oh, guck mal. Ink.
Albst gegen...
Ne, Moment. Was ist denn der Bade?
Was ist denn der Bade hier von da unten?
Ist das der Bade?
Vermutlich.
Oh, jetzt werde ich
geslampt. Das ist der Bade. Wenn der frei ist,
haben wir ziemlich die Arschkarte.
Aber wir haben keinen Heiler.
Alter, ich fass es nicht. Wir haben
niemanden, der heilt.
Ich bin der Einzige, der stirbt, Mann.
Oh, ne.
Close. Super.
Fucking close, Mann.
Moment, ich muss kurz regnen.
Ich muss mich kurz hinlegen.
Ich muss mich kurz hinlegen. Kurz chillen,
dass ich wieder Leben regeneriere.
Ich bin dead.
Geil.
Ich hatte noch sieben
Leben, Alter. So, wir haben
nichts, der wiederbeleben kann. Das heißt
Release.
Und...
Oh, ne. Shit.
Okay, ich muss da hin, ohne dass ich Buffs
kriege, was ziemlich reulich ist.
Aber wir sind ja nicht weit, zum Glück.
Oh, die sterben auch alle.
An was sterben die denn jetzt gerade?
An zwei Albs, oder wie?
An was sterben...
Ach, da sind noch Hips geadded.
Okay.
Da waren noch mehr Gegner.
Weil das waren eben Albs, die mich umgerubbelt haben.
Ist auch okay.
Guck, schon fast 33.
Einmal ordentlich gekillt.
Schon Hammer.
Fast Level 33.
Und ich glaube, dieses BG ist Level
30 bis 34.
Also, Leute, das könnten wir Level
40, wenn ich einfach
jetzt noch durchziehe, bis...
bis, ähm...
1, 20 Uhr oder so.
Da wird das...
Da wird das was noch mit Level 40 heute.
Müssen wir überlegen.
Dann war ich einfach 9 Stunden am Stück
on.
Jetzt bin ich 6 Stunden oder so on.
Äh...
Warum genau habe ich gerade XP gekriegt?
Weil irgendeiner was gekillt hat.
Ich stehe einfach...
Ich stehe einfach random rum und bekomme ein Level.
Okay, nice. Und das richtig Gute ist...
Das ist...
Wir haben endlich...
Speed.
Ich weiß, dass es die...
Alter.
Ich weiß, dass es die falsche Gruppe ist.
Ich wollte einfach mit denen gehen.
Das ist auch wieder Captain Obvious hier
in der Gruppe.
Was ist denn da links, links, links, links, links?
Ist da irgend...
Hell genug. Man sieht unter Wasser
nachts in Dark nichts, gell?
Wir könnten aber die Mobs killen,
weil die brauchen wir, glaube ich.
Hips, Westen. Okay.
Wollen wir da wirklich reininken?
Ja.
Das ist der Bade.
Bade steht.
Banshee. Leute, wir haben keine Heiler.
Wir können da nix machen.
Okay, die Heiler sind... Okay.
Die Caster sind ziemlich schnell down.
Auf, mach drauf.
Hau drauf, hau drauf, hau drauf.
Alter, hier, Assisten. Gib ihm.
Gib ihm. Der ist fast down, Mann.
Die stellen sich wieder an.
Die stellen...
Alter, das sind blaue, Mann.
Oh.
Ja gut, es war auch eine ganze Gruppe
und wir waren irgendwie vier Leute.
Ja, Quatsch. Easy. Easy.
Wir sind höheres Level.
Easy geht sowas.
Okay, ohne Support geht's nicht easy.
Das muss man sagen. Wir haben ja null Support.
Wir haben keine Heiler, keine Buffs und nix.
Also, das ist scheiße.
Also, ich guck mir das noch an.
Ein Run oder so.
Wenn das nix taucht, gehe ich hier aus dem BG raus.
Und wir machen was anderes.
Wir können doch einfach mit den anderen mitlaufen.
Weil ich will auch in der 40 werden.
Sonst ist das nix.
Und das Gute ist, mit 35 kann ich den ersten
Epic Step machen.
Und ab 40
kann ich einfach jeden Tag
zwei, drei Raids joinen und bin ratzfatz 50.
Eats.
Warum rennen wir jetzt eigentlich wieder dahin?
Ohne Support, ohne alles.
Der Bart ist doch längst wieder da.
Oh.
Unser anderer Skull, der hat schon SOS als RA.
Der ist ja richtig
High IQ Pro Gamer.
Ich hab einfach in einfachere Level-RAs gesteckt.
Und der ist schon hier
bei
bei RVR-RAs.
Wir können einfach die Mobs hier killen, man.
Was haltet ihr denn davon, Leute?
Lasst doch Quests machen.
Ja, auf.
Lasst Quests machen.
Wenn wir hier mit den ganzen mit sind,
kommen die bestimmt nicht ran.
Hier, auf, drauf.
Quests.
Ich brauch Exp.
Muss Level 40 werden heute.
Exp.
Auf, auf, Exp.
Gib ihm.
Seh, er hat schon Level ab.
Weiter.
Hier unter Wasser sind sie noch, oder?
Da unten hier.
Bashen.
Target is not in view.
Ich will den bashen, ob er in view ist oder nicht.
Oh, fuck.
Der Hüter ist ein Fieber.
Und der Hüter mit dem Schild.
Ich bin aber echt dumm.
Ich bin echt dumm, Alter.
Ich bin echt dumm.
Das ist der Bade.
Alter, der Hüter.
Was wollt ihr denn bei dem?
Der war nicht gemetzt übrigens.
Sag's nur.
Der war draußen.
Okay, der ist gleich down.
Was glaubt er sich denn mit dem Schild-Tank, Alter?
Okay, die anderen sind tot schon.
Nice.
Arpies.
So, haben wir die Sachen jetzt hier durch?
Ähm, haben wir...
Haben wir gekillt?
haben wir haben wir zwei stück brauchen wir noch zwei stück brauchen wir hier
noch zwei stück von diesen komischen alle nicht weg war noch zwei von den
mobs na gut die kann ich so noch alleine killen ja da ich mache das jetzt hier
einfach ist mir egal da drüben halb als jetzt kann man gehen jetzt quest fertig
lasse ich nicht zwei mobs stehen ich brauche jetzt kommen let's go leute
letztes mal warum lassen wir den typ jetzt auf dem auf der insel stehen
ich glaube der will ausloggen habe schon gedacht was warum einfach random
ausgesetzt auf der insel so mal schauen was als nächstes so geht
mein
wenn er vor er action ist na und man auch ein paar gegner killt dann levelt
man schon wirklich schnell hier chat was meint ihr wie lange man gebraucht hat
bis level 50 bei release von dem game meinte wie lang wie lange damals so im
durchschnitt der die leute gebraucht haben bis zur 50 bei release albion
siege captain umfrage monate ja also ich denke die
meisten leute
werden so drei vier monate gebraucht haben aber die haben damals also die
haben nicht drei vier monate in zeit gebraucht sondern insgesamt weil damals
war so dieses zehn stunden grinden am tag war noch nicht so verbreitet einfach
herr dabei war das level ist es klar das level war schwieriger das spiel war noch
ein bisschen unzugänglich da die viele hatten nicht so gute fähigkeiten auch
shit
ja das war jetzt äußerst unglücklich haben uns von der seite erwischt aber
solange die ex stimmt gab es da schon so rotations oder hätten sie mit weiß
einfach release und wieder hin sagt sagen jetzt die ränder jetzt mal
zackig hin kommen wir da unten stellten sie doch um vielleicht komme ich da
schnell hin gab es da schon hotel was meinst du mit rotations du meinst jetzt
dass die leute ihre skills immer in der richtigen reihenfolge rotieren für
maximal der근cz und sowas oder was war es weißt du die sterben code alle und
internet war teurer wobei ich hatte damals schon dsl dsl flatrate allerdings
gab es damals nur dsl mit faspa bin ich mit fasbas mit bis ich glaube torches
müssen wir werden hier noch das ist fast nehmen Westfalen den westfalen sind'd Clyde
doch das ist fast dem moment fast path ist das abschalten gewesen das war im
denutationen und ich habe aber schon 10 Stunden durch den lstage dann auf der Seite dieser
fast path ging weil man wirklich nur mit fastpath konvertierte sich jetzt wir können jetzt 대표 diese
abschalten gewesen von interleaving oder wie das hieß also hat es damals in
künstlich erhöhten ping bei dsl anschlüssen richtig dumm und okay der
typ ist einfach afk jetzt da kann ich auch disbanden aus der gruppe
ok wisst ihr was er macht man setzt sich hin
man sagt man setzt sich einfach hin wenn man chancenlos ist das so ein bisschen
disrespekt gegen die gegner ist ja das muss sein
abgeben captain gradio macht sinn noch in den bg zu bleiben
ich weiß nicht ich laufe also wenn ihre crew ok ich warte jetzt zwei minuten da
kann ich nämlich mein tosbrot essen wenn ihr den crew losläuft glaube ich mit
magie fein kreis 7 stärke 3 paris ja bisschen paris schadet nicht stärke
ja
aber sterben konstitution stärke quickness schon darauf achten dass ich so schlimm ich habe eine
richtige müll umhang an institution ist nicht so wild wir kriegen also wenn man 50 erst kriegt man
eh kann man so eine epik west machen und mit mit mit epik west bekommt man ein 50er set an
rüstung das ist nicht max cap oder so aber das ist für das erste mal besser als die ganze level
rüstung ich stellte sie einfach mit denen ich stellte es einfach mit denen hier ein bisschen
rum die sehen so aus als wissen sie was sie machen übrigens hier back vielleicht kriegen
wir noch ein bisschen was gekillt level 44 oder von level 34 oder level 35 ist dann glaube ich
das bg vorbei einmal licht an das ist auch eine richtig gute änderung an eben wenn du licht an und
aus machst das sehen die gegner nicht weil das siehst du noch du früher war das immer richtiger
loop filter wenn du in dark du hast gewartet also wenn du eine gruppe in gruppe erweitern wollten
wollte so wollen es checken ob das ein kacken du bist oder nicht hast du gewartet bis nachts und
wenn der charakter nachts geleuchtet hat wusstest du das in karten ob die letzten gruppe weil alle
die nachts die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die
leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die leute die
pass mal auf hier seitwärts streifen komanti sind schneller kommen noch badge um
noch mehr mit jetzt immer zwei gruppen jetzt können wir vielleicht sogar was reißen
man kann das sein dass diese phantasy music geschichte in die lupt den song habe doch
schon zweimal gehabt oder meine so eine zehn stunden playlist
und das hört sich einfach nur ähnlich an da oben steht was die wollen gebasht
werden die wollen richtig hart gebasht werden
der bahn will instand sterben direkt okay ich bin sie ich bin 37 sekunden
geroutet als top bleibt stehen das ist halt später bei weitem nicht mehr so
schlimm ja nicht raus please please look mich raus ja ja ja ja das ist später bei
weitem nicht mehr so schlimm weil man dann resistenzen hat gegen den
kram und jetzt
pcs ich weiß nicht ob wir das aufheben sollten ob das so eine gute idee ist
eigentlich nicht dann sieht jeder wo wir sind
oh ja die wollen wir aufheben
ach nee wird wild ok stellt taktik was haben die vor
anschleich taktik oder auch nicht wird nicht gestellt
was auf wenn es wenn das so wir sind super krass elite sind aber das sind sie
nicht weil random leute aus dem bg dann würden sie sich jetzt beschweren dass
ich ihnen hinterher laufe gibt immer mal wieder so leute was haben wir denn hier
für den ring am start
es ist ja 4 00 das ist ja eins Xi
7 dass award auf
troth anhilfen anhilfen anhilfen anhilfen anhilfen und anhelfen das leaving
um undlezze
7 ganfs
kriegt man muss sie nicht killen dann muss sie einfach nur einmal an hauen hätte ich das jetzt
nicht gemacht hätte ich ehrlich verkackt bei der quest easy mit hübsch hübsch hübsch hübsch hübsch
ich verpiss mich mal kurz und inke von der seite drauf so muss man das als solo skalte machen
ein gegner das kommt wo sich verpissen der krieg damit steckt damit aufkommen es ist es ist es ist
arsch in sind gefressen sind gefressen auf auf der muss sterben okay es ist irgendein heiler frei da
muss ich mal kurz gucken oh shit noch eine gruppe noch eine gruppe okay wir müssen uns mal kurz
verpissen warum die warum die unbedingt den den blade master assisten wollten habe ich auch nicht
verstanden
leute wo ist denn das zelt und unser zelt zum abgeben der tokens ich gebe jetzt ich gebe meine
tokens ab geht meine tokens ab und dann kriege ich noch mal level für 34 es sei denn das kieb
ist uns fragezeichen ist das kieb uns wenn das kieb uns ist dann kriegen wir keinen ja das ist uns
okay ja dann kriegen wir nix okay was haben wir noch zu killen hier matt frock und deserter ja ich
gebe jetzt die quest ab ich gebe ich gebe jetzt die quest ab und ja ich habe eine 40 90 mit dog
dog ist einfach best game ever so wir machen wieder unseren seitwärts stellt und wir schneller
durch immer sieht komplett klitsch freies game ich spiele übrigens schon ich spiele übrigens schon
seit in sechs und einhalb stunden lasst euch mal vom stream nicht verwirren der ist zwischenzeitlich
abgekackt ich habe vorhin фрnd haben wir uns zusammen im stream angefangen auf level 1 und
ich habe einfach durch gekreidet bis jetzt noch am start ninety school 70 und ja das ist ein gutes
club setup heirat scharmi okay triple the best player in the world for the best player in the world for him
their best player in the world for you rallies for the best player in the world for you rallies for you
nicht mehr gehst du in den westen sieht ja nicht nur um die welt die welt ...
das ist richtig gut im internet und eigentlich stimm ich euch ein bisschen was ich weiß es auch nicht
ich weiß nicht wie die das heißt ich weiß nicht wie die leute hier das ist nicht so einfach es hat den你想ieren
Triple Skalde ist vielleicht nicht so geil.
Aber wir sollten im BG jetzt genug Interrupt haben, die zu killen.
Vodafone, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, diesmal ist OBS gecrashed.
Aber zumindest schon mal ein ganz brauchbares Probesetup.
Triple Skald ist halt nicht so das, was ich spielen würde.
Aber im BG kann man sich das nicht aussuchen.
Ich flex ein bisschen den Realm Rank Titel.
Wobei halt auch RR6, ich war kurz vor RR7, hätte ich noch fertig spielen sollen.
Nicht so geil ist.
Also auf Phoenix war ich innerhalb der ersten paar Monate RR9.
Da habe ich wirklich so den krass, auf Phoenix habe ich so den mega Ultra Grind gestartet.
Ich habe Stunden gespielt, täglich man.
Ich war irgendwie zwei Monate nach Release oder drei Monate, oder zwei, zwei Monate nach Release war ich irgendwie RR9.
Da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Wir haben ganz kurz...
Ich habe mal Phoenix gestreamt damals auch für ein paar Stunden.
Aber Phoenix am Anfang war auch einfach mit den RVR Belohnungen und allem.
Okay, was geht hier?
Nichts.
Doch, da sind sie doch.
Da sind sie doch.
Moment, die sind mit.
Kein Quade.
War überhaupt keine Gegner.
Man kann sagen.
Hipcrop, wo ist Hipcrop?
Ich sehe keine.
Ah.
Oh, der muss verrecken.
Da ist übrigens so ein Pilz.
Jetzt platzen sie.
Alter, jetzt platzen sie.
Kackpilz, verpiss dich.
Oh, ne.
Dieser räudige Kackpilz, Mann.
Bade, wenn du castest.
Ich lasse dich nicht casten, Bade.
Kannst du vergessen.
Jawoll.
Bade, Bade.
Platz, Platz, Platz.
Alter, hau drauf.
Ey, der Typ, dieser dreckige Kackpilz.
Der fuckt mich so ab.
Bade ist wieder am Start.
Bleibst du stehen?
Alter, da sind noch mehr geedet.
Fuck.
Oh, ne.
Fuck, der hat es durch, durch strafen gecheckt.
Oh, ich bin dead.
Fuck.
Da sind wieder welche drauf geedet.
Es waren am Anfang nur acht.
Und jetzt sind es wieder was weiß ich wie viele.
Machste nix.
Next.
Gab gute Applaus.
Ja.
Gab gute RP.
Gute RP und gute Ex- Level 34.
So kann das ruhig noch ein bisschen weiter gehen.
Dann sind wir fast 35.
Und wenn wir 35 sind, dann sind wir ja schon fast 40.
So ist es.
Oder?
Da haben wir es fast schon, fast schon geschafft.
Ein paar Trauben futtern.
Ich habe hier so ein paar dunkle Trauben vom Lidl.
Ja?
Ich finde, die schmecken übelst, als hätten sie voll den krassen Alkoholgehalt.
Haben sie nicht, weil sie sind einfach Trauben.
Ja, haben sie noch nicht.
Aber die schmecken so.
Die schmecken, als bist du besoffen, wenn du da ein Bündel von isst.
Bist du natürlich nicht, aber ganz weird.
Keine Ahnung, warum das so ist.
Raub und Fäule, die sind nicht faul, die sind richtig prall.
Oh ne.
Oh ne, ich dachte, ihr rennt gerade hips von der Seite drauf von dem Spell.
Hartbender Feinbelt.
8 plus 1 Melee Weapon.
Komplett useless shit.
Useless shit.
Droppt, droppt, nur Schrott.
Also ich brauche, ich brauche bald ein neues Schwert.
Ich brauche, ähm, ich brauche eigentlich alles neu.
Haben wir eigentlich alle Klassen fertig behandelt?
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Hatten wir Nightshade, lassen wir Ranger, lassen wir auch.
Veil Walker, ja, stimmt.
Wir haben noch drei Klassen.
Klassen offen für Hip.
So, wie ich euch mal sagen wollte, falls ihr Hip anfangen möchtet.
Was ich nicht empfehlen würde, aber man weiß ja nie.
Äh, Veil Walker.
Tatsächlich einer der spannendsten of Tanks, Hybrid of Tanks.
Auf Deutsch hieß der Schnitter.
Ist ein, ähm, Tank, der casten kann und eine Sense am Start hat.
Macht mit der Sense nicht so krass Damage, aber...
Wenn die passenden Style Kombis durchgehen, macht er richtig gut Schaden durch die Prox.
Also der erste, der erste Nahkampfschlag macht nicht so viel Schaden.
Der zweite mehr, der dritte mehr, der vierte quasi richtig viel dann.
Und zusätzlich können, äh, können Veil Walker auch ein bisschen casten.
Eigentlich ein ziemlich spannender Caster Tank Hybrid.
Den so.
Aber eigentlich, wenn man denkt passt gar nicht zusammen, aber Schnitter ist echt ganz gut.
Also wenn man Bock hat auf einen Nahkämpfer, der auch ein bisschen casten kann und ein bisschen Finesse braucht, sagen wir mal so, beim Positioning, ist Schnitter auch eine gute, gute Klasse.
Wobei ich sagen würde, vielleicht nicht unbedingt die beste Einsteiger of Tank Klasse.
So, und dann haben wir als letztes noch, ich glaube Vampir gibt es auf Eden nicht.
Glaube ich, bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Die haben ja neue Sachen gebracht mit der Season 2, aber ich glaube Vampir gibt es nicht.
Vampir ist auch eine dumme Klasse.
Ähm, da gibt es Warden.
Eines der besten Support Klassen im Spiel, meiner Meinung nach.
Hier auf Eden, gerade mit Schildspeck.
Ist ein Support Tank Hybrid.
Macht kein Damage.
Hat zwar Waffenspeck und eine Waffe, macht aber keinen Schaden großartig damit.
Kann Schildspecken, kann also Gegner stunnen.
Und, äh, kann richtig gut heilen.
Und hat eine Fähigkeit, die ziemlich unik ist.
Halt in den Specklinien.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Gegner!
Geh schnauze, geh schnauze!
Moment, das sind...
Okay, Leute.
Dieser Dreckspilz, Alter.
Dieser Kackpilz.
Ich, ich werde den Pilz zerstören, bevor ich, bevor ich irgendwie auf den Gegner drüber...
Das ist übrigens ein Hüter hier, glaube ich.
Wo wir es gerade davon hatten.
Ein, ein Ward, Wardel.
Es könnte auch ein Druide sein mit einem großen Schild.
Da kommen noch mehr, mehr, mehr, mehr, mehr.
Alps, Alps, Alps, Alps.
Guck mal, die Leute sind wieder afk.
Brain afk.
Die gucken nicht hin.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich habe es noch in den Chat geschrieben.
Fucking shit, Mann.
Okay, ich bin gefickt.
Solange die jetzt nicht reinrushen, bin ich richtig...
Hau mich...
Ja, aber ich muss weg.
Ich kriege gerade richtig Damage.
Das, das Simmo soll ruhig auf mir bleiben.
Das schlägt mich aus, aus, aus...
allem raus.
Okay.
Immer dran denken, Alps sind schlecht.
Alps sind schlecht.
Und dann gewinnt man auch.
Easy.
Ja.
Siehst du?
Wie ich es gesagt habe.
Alps sind schlecht.
Also, easy win.
Ist so.
Die meisten Alps sucken einfach so krass in dem Game.
Das ist Wahnsinn, ey.
Die haben uns so hard assed, assjammed.
Bei uns haben sogar Leute auf dem Boden gesessen.
Und die haben es geschafft, ganze zwei Leute zu CCen.
Da waren die anderen noch nicht am Start.
Wir haben ein Ammo gedroppt.
Dex, Cold.
Das brauche ich auch nicht.
Ink?
Noch mehr Ink?
Wo denn?
Oh, da.
Schon wieder Hips.
Du bleibst stehen.
Dieser Dreckspilz, Alter.
Bade, dreh dich um.
Wie ich es hasse.
Wir dürfen uns, wir dürfen uns nicht zu sehr extenden lassen.
Wir brauchen wieder Speed.
Ich muss warten, bis ich Speed habe.
Wenn ich wieder Speed habe, kann ich wieder engagen.
Oh, da kommen noch mehr Hips.
Shit.
Wir sind gefickt.
Oh, da kommt noch mehr Hips.
Shit.
Wir sind gefickt.
Oh, da kommt noch mehr Hips.
Shit.
Wir sind gefickt.
Oh, da kommt noch mehr Hips.
Shit.
Wir sind gefickt.
Wir können höchstens noch den Typ hier umrubbeln.
Und dann sind wir dead.
Weil noch eine Gruppe von der Seite verkraften wir jetzt nicht.
Ich meine, wir fighten.
Da kommen ja noch mehr.
Alter, wie viele, wie viele kommen da noch?
Ist das der Bade?
Das ist der Bade.
Okay, der Bade disengaged sofort.
Ist auch nice.
Und meine Leute gucken wieder nicht hin.
What the fuck?
Alter.
Jetzt kloppen wir wieder auf Tanks rum, Mann.
Das ist so dumm.
Okay, das sind aber auch wieder richtig viele.
Macht aber auch nichts.
Ich meine, das Keep ist hier vorne.
Guck.
Hier.
Aus der Richtung kommen die halt.
Angerannt.
Ja, jetzt sind wir wieder dead.
Aber gut XP.
Richtig gut XP gegeben.
Ey, ohne Scheiß.
So kann ich das bis Level 35 machen.
Fünf Minuten.
Halbes Level.
Weiter geht's.
Easy.
Gar kein, gar kein Thema.
Um nicht zu sagen.
Sekunde.
Easy.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Mega easy.
Genau.
Vor allem Low-IQ-Stream.
Stellt euch mal vor, wie easy das wäre, wäre es High-IQ-Stream gewesen.
Das ist, das ist jetzt easy, das wäre dann einfach hyper-mega-easy gewesen.
Wie wär's mit nicht alleine losrennen?
Leute, wie wär's mit...
Oh, random Koops, Mann.
Warum laufen die jetzt alleine los?
Wollen die irgendwie weg, weg gutcherollt werden von der Seite?
Oh, random Koops, Mann.
Warum laufen die jetzt alleine los? Wollen die irgendwie weg, weg gutcherollt werden von der Seite?
Wollen die irgendwie weg, weg gutcherollt werden von der Seite?
Oder wie?
Ich meine, wir haben schon Probleme, es mit der Masse an Leuten aufzunehmen in Full-Group, ja?
Und die denken sich so, ach nee, wir rennen einfach mal zu dritt los.
Was, was soll da schon schiefgehen?
Ja, easy.
Oh, und jetzt können die auf die Map gucken und sehen, dass wir hinter ihm sind und einfach mal einen Loop machen, dass wir zusammenlaufen.
So sieht's aus.
Aber die kennen da nix.
Die rennen einfach weiter.
Du-du-du-du.
Ach ja, noch mal was zur 4090.
Ich glaube, Dark läuft heute echt auf jeder Krücke.
Oh, pass auf, pass auf, pass auf.
Ich wusste es.
Äh, hallo?
Team?
Na gut, dann halt nicht.
Oh, nee.
Geil.
Nice, sehr gut.
Oh, doch?
Also, okay, seriously.
Dass, dass die Leute das nicht gecheckt haben, dass da ein Gegner war, ist absolut lächerlich.
What the fuck, Leute?
What the fuck?
We, we were going back to rest.
Woher soll ich das wissen?
Ihr habt's ja vorher schon auch nicht gecheckt.
Alter, Mann, ey, ich fass es nicht.
Okay, da kommt gerade eine Battle Group auf meine Group zu.
Die werden jetzt gleich easy gereckt, glaube ich.
Muss aufpassen, dass ich nicht wieder weg, weggestellt werde von der Seite.
Äh.
What? Alter.
Alter, wo rennt ihr denn hin?
Team?
Ist ja fast wie in Battlefield, Mann.
So viele, so viele sind das gar nicht.
So viele sind das gar nicht.
Okay.
Bade am Start.
Jawoll.
Glaube ich.
Zumindest der Kälte.
Kälte sind meistens Baden.
Und gerade, also, wenn ihr den Kälte seht, der vorne wegläuft, der, äh, wenn in Kälte
vorne wegläuft, ist die Chance, dass es ein Bade ist, relativ hoch.
Die laufen übrigens direkt.
Zurück zum Hip-Keep.
Aber den hinteren, den könnten wir noch.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Nein.
Alter.
Oh, die sind so dumm.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich hab.
Okay.
Nur, nur, nur mal, dass ihr es mitkriegt, was gerade passiert ist.
Ja.
Pass auf, jetzt werden sie Gemessler.
Perfekt.
Nur mal, dass, dass ihr mitkriegt, was gerade passiert ist.
Ich hab so einen Instant-Snare, das slowt die Gegner um 40 Prozent.
Und.
Ja, das ist Eden Dark und falls du früher Dark gespielt hast, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass dir das auch gefällt, denn die haben am Dienstag, nee, am Samstag, guck mal, es sind 729 Leute online, nur auf mit, insgesamt sind also quasi gerade 2.100 Leute online und Wochenende sogar noch mehr, also das ist richtig, richtig huge gerade.
Custom Server mit sehr vielen wirklich nicen Änderungen, sie haben sogar Home Invasion Events, wo du dann quasi bis zur Hauptstadt rüber kannst, ja, ist schon cool, ist schon wirklich nice gemacht.
Okay, ich glaube, das hier war es jetzt in dem WG, wir brauchen noch 4 Bubble bis, ist Killer rausgelevelt aus dem WG? Ah, da ist 35, da ist rausgelevelt, ja, okay.
Okay, also wir brauchen noch 4 Bubble, das können wir entweder durch ein paar Mobs oder, ähm, ich meine, ich meine, wir sind Heiler, Charmy, Skull, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so, dass wir killen eine ganze Grupp-Trio, wahrscheinlich kriegen wir jetzt auf den Sack, also wenn wir jetzt nochmal auf den Sack kriegen, dann gehe ich raus und mache schnell 2 Kill-Quests und dann machen wir weiter, weil das hältst du ja dann aus.
Okay, also ich kann es echt nur jedem empfehlen, der früher ein bisschen Dark gespielt hat, oh, Trinkets, ach, Moment, ich kann die Trinkets ja nicht rein, weil das Keep uns ist, oder war doch so, das Keep war doch uns, korrekt, oder war das der letzte WG, ne, ich glaube, es war dieser WG, wo das Keep uns ist.
Okay, wir stehen einfach random rum, weil...
Buffen im Wald.
Auch so ein Tipp, den ich euch geben kann.
Versucht, wenn ihr nicht stehen müsst, nie zu stehen.
Ihr könnt es an einer Hand abzählen, wo ich heute mal in irgendwas länger stand als ein paar Sekunden.
Oder wenn überhaupt.
Du musst einfach...
Guck mal, ey, die Leute.
Du musst einfach immer ein bisschen in Bewegung sein.
Der Ambro ist einfach beim Loslaufen AFK.
Mitten im BG.
Mitten im PvP-Gebiet, hat er sich gedacht.
Weißt du was?
Wir gehen mal AFK.
Coole Idee.
Direkt in Front von den Gegnern.
Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal AFK.
Mr. Amek, danke für den...
Ah, da ist er wieder.
Mit Gott.
Revenge.
So wird das mit Revenge, aber nix.
Für Revenge muss man Leute bashen und nicht AFK im PvP-Gebiet gehen.
Ich überlege gerade, was wir vorhaben.
Ein paar Deserter killen oder irgendwas.
Ich meine, wir können zu viert jetzt nicht allzu viel machen.
Das sind Full-Groups, die hier rumrennen von den Gegnern.
Guck mal, der stirbt wieder.
Der ist einfach nicht...
Der ist sonst wo.
Guckt ihn euch an.
Das sind einfach wieder die besten Leute am Start.
Wir wurden echt verwöhnt, ey.
Wir wurden echt verwöhnt heute Morgen mit den ersten paar BG-Groups.
Da seht ihr mal, das ist nicht...
Das ist im BG nicht normal, dass das so gut flutscht wie heute Morgen.
Ich hab das ja heute Morgen schon gelobt.
Hab ich gesagt, okay, ey, guck mal.
Da sind Leute dabei, die wissen, wie man spielt.
Aber...
Aber hier auch.
Also ich muss sagen, gerade Killer hat keinen schlechten Eindruck gemacht als Valk.
Das Charme auch nicht.
Der Heiler macht auch einen guten Eindruck.
Aber wir sind einfach nicht genug.
Oh, fuck.
Ey, Leute, das ist der ganze Crew.
Wollt ihr da wirklich...
Ja!
LOL!
Die sind ja genauso verplant wie wir, Alter.
Die sind ja genauso verplant.
Die sind ja genauso verplant wie wir, die Hips, Mann.
Ich konnte einfach den Caster rauskillen, mitten aus der Crew, Mann.
Okay, die sind genauso verplant, Alter.
LOL, Mann.
Geil.
Okay.
Ähm...
Dann...
Machen wir jetzt noch eine Quest.
Und dann sind wir 35.
Nice.
Okay, lasst mal kurz ins Wiki gucken.
Ich brauch mal ein bisschen was abseits...
von PvP-Gebiet.
Lass mal kurz ins Wiki gucken.
Wir sind 34, ne?
Oh, da können wir...
Da können wir die Skona-Runde eigentlich gleich machen.
Ne, wir machen Moon in Sound.
Moon in Sound ist eine nette Zone.
Oder wir killen ein paar Mammuts.
Hm.
Eigentlich?
Okay, ab wann ist Warland Swamp?
35, okay.
Wir machen jetzt...
zwei Quests in Skona.
Und...
Und danach machen wir weitere Quests ins...
Wobei, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Skona hat easy Quests.
Äh, Skona ist...
Hier.
Bis 35.
Bis 35 machen wir jetzt.
Da ist nicht viel, außer ein paar Hütten, ne?
So, wir müssen jetzt erstmal trainieren.
Speck.
Ah, mehr geht nicht.
Train.
Schwertspeck.
Also, ich brauch 34.
34 Schwert für einen neuen, guten Anytime-Style.
Das wird erstmal nix.
Battle Songs.
Jawoll.
Äh, welcher ist das?
War.
Nice.
Skona-Stelz.
Easy.
Guck mal hier, ist direkt um die Ecke.
Ups.
Direkt um die Ecke.
Zwei Quests.
Easy, easy Level 35.
Zack.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, Wehrwölfe müssen gebasht werden, ne?
Äh, was machen wir denn?
Oh.
Wir könnten auch, wenn wir genug Endu haben, und wir haben genug Endu...
Könnte man eigentlich auch den Barrier, Barrier und Nahkampf.
Ich glaub, das ist eine gute Kombi hier für Solo-Quests.
Da machen die weniger Damage.
Mit Endu-Pot hab ich genug Endu.
Und da werden die Two-Hitted hier.
Was braucht man eigentlich?
Skona.
Äh, irgendeinen Unique-Mob killen.
Und...
Noch...
Ja, auf.
Sterb mal.
Und noch sieben Wehrwölfe.
Easy.
Leute.
Ab sieb...
Ab 40 ist es viel einfacher zu leveln, als bis 40.
Normalerweise ist das eigentlich umgedreht.
Aber ab 40 gibt es so viele Raids und so viele Sachen, die permanent laufen, wo man mitkann.
Die man früher oder später eh machen muss.
Das heißt, am besten ist eigentlich, man levelt so ab 45 ganz normal mit, äh, Quests, also nicht mit, nicht mit dem Quest, sondern mit ganz normalen Raid-Quests, weil du brauchst später für Endgame-Gear eh die ganzen, äh, High-Level-Sachen und Währungen und sowas.
Deswegen ist es am besten, man fängt gleich mit 45 schon an.
Was haben wir da?
Äh.
Die will ich nicht.
Three-Head.
Ah, Massive Three-Head.
So eine Guard.
Herzman.
Wie darf ich alles killen?
Nur Werwolf-Guards.
Okay.
Moin, Max, du Zahnt.
Ist das dein...
Ups.
Sorry.
Krieg ich das Mikrofon?
Komm.
Ist das mein uralt MMO?
Jop.
Das ist mein uralt MMO.
Das beste PvP-MMO ever.
Was...
Alter, wer hat sich...
Was haben die sich bei der Animation gedacht, ey?
Aber...
Aber ich muss gerade noch leveln.
Noch...
Noch ist es nur ansatzweise best PvP ever.
Wobei ich finde, man hat ja heute schon in den Battle-Corns durchaus gesehen, dass PvP wirklich mega in dem Game ist.
Und das alles, weil es drei Fraktionen gibt.
Oder es ist die Base des Ganzen.
Ach, kurz.
Tja, wäre ich schon 40, dann könnte ich jetzt den Mana-Pot saufen und alles wäre gut.
Geht aber nicht.
Wie viel Charisma habe ich eigentlich?
Null!
Okay.
Meine Ausrüstung ist Official-Schrott.
Aber wenigstens...
Wenigstens...
Ich habe ja nix...
Alter, das ist ja richtig schlecht, meine Ausrüstung, man.
Ich muss danach unbedingt mal zum Quarter-Meister und mir gescheite Ausrüstung holen.
Das ist ja mal super mies, man.
Ich habe meine Damage-Stats nicht capped.
Ich habe meinen Caster-Stat nicht capped.
Ich habe...
Okay, dafür habe ich Resis.
Das, was ich zum Leveln nicht brauche.
Nice.
Äh, Moment.
Ist es nicht durch?
Nicht schon geschafft?
Nee, Moment.
Ich bin noch fertig.
Ich bin schon fertig.
Noch schon durch.
Hopp.
Auf.
Oh.
Come on.
Hau einmal drauf.
Okay, wir geben das jetzt ab.
Geben die Quest jetzt ab und gucken mal, wie viel wir noch brauchen bis 35.
So, hier könnten wir jetzt eine Riesenrunde machen.
Aber ich gucke mal, ob ich den Named vorher noch weg bekomme.
Wir sind nämlich schon...
Alter, wie viel XP gab denn das?
Das gab ja gefühlt irgendwie ein drittel Level oder so.
Das ist ja richtig pog.
So, hier unten sollen wir noch irgendeinen Named killen.
Das machen wir schnell noch.
Und dann gucken wir...
Ich überlege gerade.
BG und Polemo.
Okay.
Es geht los, Leute.
Aber wir spielen...
Wir machen heute kein großes RVR mit 35.
Das hat keinen Sinn.
Erstmal Leveln Epic machen und ein bisschen, ein bisschen ansatzweise gescheite Ausrüstung zusammen...
Zusammen krassen.
Okay.
So, hier ist angeblich ein Named, den wir killen müssen.
Hier.
Irgendwo.
So.
Da.
Hier müsste es einen Gegner geben, der...
Tradunday heißt.
Seht ihr irgendwo was?
Ich seh nix.
Da.
Great Tingler.
Ich sehe nix.
Wahrscheinlich hat den gerade jemand gekillt und wir müssen zwei Minuten warten.
Chat, gibt es irgendwelche wichtigen Themen, über die wir reden müssen?
Wenn ich hier zwei Minuten sinnlos rumstehe.
Morgen wieder Kreisel-Cryin'.
Bis ich 50 bin, ja.
Ich muss aufholen.
Weil ich habe zuerst den Alp gelevelt.
Und in Alp habe ich jetzt so mal die Baselings fertig.
Und ich muss aufholen, dass ich auch einen 50er mithabe, der demnächst ganz brauchbar equipped ist.
Dazu muss ich 40 werden.
Wenn ich 40 bin, ist das alles kein Problem mehr.
Weil mit 40 kannst du dich einfach vormittags an zwei, drei Raids dranhängen.
Da kriegst du jedes Mal ein Level.
Und dann nebenbei noch ein bisschen und easy fertig, ja.
Aber man muss 40 werden, weil die ganzen...
Die ganzen Endgame-Raids und so, die haben mindest Level 40 für die Quests.
Das heißt, das Wichtigste ist, 40 zu werden.
Also genau hier sollte eigentlich jetzt der Boss stehen.
Macht er aber nicht.
Hat er keinen Bock.
Ich warte hier noch zwei Minuten.
Ah, da ist er doch.
Eats.
Und wenn ich 40 bin, ist gut.
Dann ist easy.
Jawoll.
So.
Wir porten zurück.
Wenn das Ding hat einen One-Time-Drop.
Okay, richtig Schrott.
Braucht niemanden.
Schon angeguckt.
Moment.
Ich muss erst mal abgeben.
Ich bin ja blöd.
Ich wollte schon zurückporten.
Ich muss die Quest erst mal abgeben.
Das geht schneller als zu porten, das Stückchen zurückrennen.
Au.
Mach ich mal eine Lampe an.
Und dann muss ich unbedingt mal zum Quartermaster und mir ordentliches Equip kaufen.
Also ist richtig Schrott.
Ich meine, es...
Von den Leveln her geht's noch, aber...
Okay, gab nur einen Bubble.
Hat sich nicht wirklich gelohnt.
Okay, dann porten wir mal kurz.
So, wir schauen ganz kurz ins nächste BG.
Gucken, ob da irgendwie krass die mitruhlen und alles backbashen.
Dann kreiselgrinden wir da kurz mit.
Wenn nicht BG...
Dann weiß ich nicht.
So langsam oder sicher kann ich mich auch nicht mehr so hundertprozentig konzentrieren.
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt...
Seit wann war ich in Ordnung?
13 Uhr oder so?
Nee, 12.30 Uhr.
Irgendwie 7, 7,5 Stunden oder so.
Und...
Falls ihr irgendwie nur lurkt oder so und irgendwas zum Game wissen wollt, sagt Bescheid.
So, Quests annehmen.
So, die können mich vielleicht wieder in den Group inviten, weil die waren ja ganz fähig.
So, lass mal kurz schauen, was brauche ich denn auf jeden Fall?
Wie viele Bounty Points haben wir denn?
Mehr als genug.
Mehr als genug, um uns ordentliche Ausrüstung zu kaufen.
So, Sell.
Nee, das wollen sie nicht, dann ist es halt vernichtet.
Wenn sich das...
Alter, wenn sich das nicht sellen lässt...
Äh...
Sell...
Will er auch nicht sellen, ne?
Ach, Moment!
Der...
Der Händler will das einfach nur nicht.
Wait a minute.
Bin ich jetzt...
Bin ich jetzt komplett verwirrt?
Moment, der Händler will das alles nicht.
Oh!
Ich habe jetzt unsinnige Items zerstört, okay.
Ähm...
S...
Von Destroyern...
Brauchen wir hier...
Nee.
Steuerung S, Steuerung S...
Sellen...
Taugt das was?
Äh... Steuerung S...
Steuerung S...
Ich destroy... Ich bin braindead...
Okay, das will ich nicht zerstören.
Auf Wilton bin ich weg.
Jetzt sind wir in Modend Day.
weg jetzt immer ein ball weg bremer kann man löschen immer löschen sondern kommt
der trank noch da oben hin trank trank exzellent okay let's go sondern kauf
einmal kurz ordentliches equipment wir kaufen uns gekauft und so komplett
neues set also dass das dass das was haben wir denn hier bei 80 ja das doch ganz gut
weil das neues equipment kaufen schuhe beine jetzt gibt es ja sogar skins mittlerweile jetzt
haben wir hier richtig
ja richtig richtig advanced high level optik schon das haben die rüstung ja schon skins
brauchen wir hier noch irgendwas eine waffe oder so was haben wir hier moivic greatsword
11,2 ja das hält ein bisschen länger und bounty points scheiß drauf ich habe genug
da ist das sieht auch schon ganz gut schon deutlich besser aus so und jetzt ich brauche
noch ein bisschen was für für meine stats
meine stats nämlich richtig mies so guck mal stärke konstitution ist pad
quickness ist fastcamp charisma ist okay ich brauche stärke und charisma was haben
wir denn da so 00
der schrott schrott schrott schrott schrott für michcribed Lastly!
stärke das gut die clock i lack would you selling in ruder
they are good so much strength lul stealth leaker man some kind of shit
Ist nice.
Ja, die ist richtig gut.
Stärke cap.
Konstitution cap.
Quickness cap.
Charisma nicht wirklich cap.
Aber das ist okay.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein bisschen
Charisma.
Speed habe ich selbst. Brauche ich nicht.
Hatte irgendwas davon?
Equity
oder Charisma?
Ah, doch hier.
Necklace.
Das müsste ich
dafür austauschen.
Dextril Melee ist okay. Kaufen.
Nice. Okay.
Jetzt sehen wir doch statmäßig schon
ganz brauchbar aus. Resis sind
nicht total kacke im Keller.
Äh, halbwegs hier ordentlich.
Alles... Ja. Ja, ja.
Okay, das ist schon mal deutlich
besser.
Merchant.
Sell, sell, sell.
Das kann man
nur zerstören. Das will ich...
Wollen die nicht.
Sell, sell.
So zerstörbar.
Sell.
Gut, jetzt sind wir ready.
Richtiges Endgame.
Hey, wir sehen... Guck mal, Leute.
Wir sehen jetzt schon deutlich
professioneller aus als noch vorhin, ja?
So, mal schauen hier.
Moll Vic. Wie viele Mids am Start sind?
Wow, richtig viele Mids am Start.
Da schauen wir doch mal, was hier abgeht.
Vielleicht kriegen wir was gekillt.
Bisschen schön reinleachen, ja?
Ähm...
Sieht man irgendwo vielleicht ein paar Mids rumlaufen?
Es sind auf jeden Fall viele da.
Äh,
Puh, Moll Vic.
Es sind, äh,
über 26.
Oh, fuck. Das ist ja gar nicht unser Tower.
Lull.
Oh, lass mich mit. Lass mich mit drauf hauen.
Haben wir Glück gehabt.
Was brauche ich für die Quest?
Alter, der Gildenname, Leute.
French Special Forces.
Alles klar.
Die Franzosen sind da schon immer sehr speziell.
Äh...
French Special Forces.
Jetzt hauen die wieder ab.
Ich stell's jetzt mal denen rum und leech in die Mobs rein,
dass ich die Quest möglichst schnell durchkrieg.
Ich weiß, was die machen.
Die suchen diese...
diese Katzenviecher.
Da, hier. So was suchen die zum Beispiel.
So was suchen die zum Beispiel.
Timbercats.
Moment.
Die sind auch blind. Die haben nicht gesehen, dass hier was spawnt.
Ey, guck mal.
Eine Croup. An die kann ich mich dranhängen.
Velopumpi.
Ist das eine
Anspielung auf,
dass er immer auf dem Fahrrad pumpt?
Oder...
Ja, Fahrradpumpe. Sowas.
Oder er pumpt auf dem
Fahrrad. Je nachdem.
Gibt es verschiedene Interpretationsmöglichkeiten.
Leute, wir haben einen Shummy,
der mich bufft. Von sich aus.
Monks, was ist da los?
Ah, Velo...
Fahrradpumpe.
Der Gildenname ist gut, oder?
Only Friends.
Das finde ich
mal einen kreativen Gildennamen.
Only Friends.
Mir schreibt gerade jemand von
Season 1 an. Bin ich froh, dass es noch
ein paar gibt, die auch noch spielen.
So.
Wann war denn Season 1?
Season 1 war
von letztem Dezember
bis...
ähm...
September.
Wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege.
So um...
Sag mal mal...
Wobei September könnte es schon... Irgendwie bis September...
Es waren irgendwie so sieben...
Ne, es...
So acht, neun Monate war Season 1.
Oh, oh.
Bade, Bade, Bade, Bade.
Hier vorne ist der Bade.
Der haut ab.
Jetzt habe ich ihn. Ich habe ihn.
So nicht, Kollege.
So nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
So nicht.
Ey, was castet ihr hier?
Was ist denn nur mit casten los?
Was ist denn nur mit
casten los?
Ah, ich wollte den Slowdown, dass
der Bersi... Ne, das Galde. Was ist das?
Das Galde hinterher kommt.
Oh. Noch mehr?
Direkt in den Metz gestellt.
So muss das sein. Und du kack, Anni.
Pilz... Pilzman.
Du kriegst das direkt auf den Sack.
Guck hier, da ist er.
Kann er nur quick casten, seinen dummen Pilz. Sonst kann er nix.
Ich hasse Annis. Wer merkt es vielleicht?
Rekt. Einfach nur...
Ah, guck mal, Deserters. Da hauen wir doch mal mit rein.
Die Group, die läuft ganz gut hier.
Da merkst du auch wieder...
... grad bisschen...
... socializen im Chat.
Okay. So.
Hoffentlich sind die noch nicht rausgelevelt, weil...
... ich würde tatsächlich noch gerne
ein paar Runden mit denen spielen.
Es läuft nämlich gut mit der Gruppe.
Okay, die lau...
... die laufen jetzt hier...
Vielleicht können wir abkürzen.
So ein bisschen... So ein bisschen jibäden.
Ja, ja, ja, pass mal auf.
Wir erwischen die. Wir erwischen die.
Guck mal, die laufen schräg.
Die laufen schräg.
Ah, ne, ne.
Doch nicht.
Na? Na?
Jawoll!
Bam!
Wenigstens einen erwischt, Mann.
Jetzt turnen sie.
Nein, Kollege.
Du machst nix. Du machst nix.
Okay, Jungs.
Auf.
Ich warte. Ich warte auf euch,
dass ihr den Baden ownen könnt.
So ist das gut.
So ist das gut. Da weißt du gleich, dass du mit Leuten spielst,
die das Game schon mal gespielt haben.
Ich brauche noch ein paar von den Mobs.
Ähm, lass mal kurz gucken.
Was brauche ich noch? Molvik?
Katz. Zwei Stück. Die kann ich zur Not solo machen, die Quest.
Groovewood. Ah, wir müssen doch wieder Bäume
killen und irgendwelche komischen Ghouls.
Oh, ist der Typ da?
Ah!
Unser Siege-Dude ist da. Nice.
Gab ein bisschen Exp.
Müssen wir die Viecher killen?
Ah, ja.
Gibt es hier nur einen Mob?
Na los.
Oh, seitlich. Seitlich.
Stelzen. Alps West.
Okay.
Ah, hier auf der anderen Seite. Habt ihr sie gesehen?
Auf der anderen Seite sind Kelten
und...
Okay, Achtung. Hier sind Gegner am Start.
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Let's go.
Oh, bashen, bashen, bashen. Alter, bashen.
Du bleibst mal kurz stehen,
bis wir die anderen gebasht haben. Okay.
Das ist doch geil, wenn man die
abstellen kann, Mann. Wow.
Alter.
Das macht ja so viel Schaden.
Da mage man.
So, und jetzt den Clary killen.
So, das ist halt das Ding in Dark.
Du musst... Leute, wenn ich den Typ sehe,
erkenne ich sofort, das ist ein Heiler.
Weil Bretonne beliebt dafür.
Schild und Kette.
Und allein schon, wie er da steht und gelaufen ist,
erkennt man sofort, das ist ein Heiler.
Dementsprechend Heiler abstellen, Tanks killen
ist eine valide Taktik.
Wenn nicht die ganze Group direkt auf den Heiler geht.
Ja, wäre auch eine Möglichkeit gewesen.
Das ist das Ding.
Dark ist Mechanics-technisch.
Also so, so.
Du brauchst in Dark kein Aiming.
Du brauchst nicht super krasse Reactions.
Du brauchst
nicht super krasses Movement, nix.
Das ist ein olles MMO, da geht das überhaupt nicht.
Was du in Dark brauchst, ist halbwegs
Kenntnis darüber, wie du das Game
findest. Das ist das, wo sich
dran auszeichnet, ob die Leute halbwegs
was auf die Reihe kriegen oder nicht.
Also Basic Knowledge
reicht erstmal. Also muss man vermissen,
wie sieht ein Gegner, welche Klasse ist das, wann
greift man den an. Also vor allem, wenn man
sowas hier spielt. Wenn man Zerg RvR
spielt, ist es eh egal.
Ja.
Also quasi mit
100 gegen 100, dann ist es wurscht.
Dann ist es einfach eh Spammen, bis alles umfällt.
Ich muss sagen, früher habe ich das
gehasst.
Zerg RvR.
Aber mittlerweile
gefällt mir das am liebsten.
Früher war ich so richtig elitärer
8 vs 8
Verfechter,
das über alle Leute lustig gemacht hat,
die keinen Bock hatten, so zu spielen.
Aber mittlerweile bin ich halt auch
der richtige nice Casual,
der am liebsten sinnlos
rumzerkt
und sich
vom Krieche
zur Sau machen lässt.
Hehehe.
Ich habe ja schon mal BG RvR
mit Polemo gestreamt.
Ich habe aber halt den Discord nicht an,
weil das finde ich immer
irgendwie so, wie soll ich sagen, privatsphärenmäßig
so in Anführungsstrichen immer doof,
wenn du im Discord bist mit ganz vielen Leuten
und die wissen halt nicht, dass du streamst und man hört die Leute.
Und vor allem
bist du halt auch selbst
übelst im Arsch, wenn da im
Discord
irgendein random Dude
das N-Wort droppt
oder sowas. Man weiß ja nie, was du da für Leute drin
hast im Vorfeld, ja. Da sind ja teilweise
50, 60 Leute im Discord.
Und dann kriegst du im Zweifelsfall noch eine Verwarnung
und einen Bann temporär auf Twitch, weil irgendein
random Dude rumgeflucht
hat im Discord.
Also das Risiko will ich da gar nicht eingehen.
Also ich müsste quasi alle muten, außer Polemo
und selbst Polemo schreit manchmal rum.
Also will ich nicht einfach ungefragt Leute streamen.
Das heißt, ich werde höchstens
selbst im Discord, so dass ich's
höre, aber halt nicht für den Stream.
Was ultra lustig ist bei dem
in der BG, weil der steigert
sich immer so krass rein
in das Game. Also wenn ihr
manchmal denkt so, ich bin hier schon voll dabei,
ja, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also
Polemo ist auf komplett anderem Level,
was reinsteigern angeht in das Game, man.
Das ist so weit
bei dem, dass er für alle seine
Taktiken schon eigene Namen hat
und sowas.
Was ist da oben? Da oben ist Ink.
Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink.
Oh fuck, weggeslampt.
Oh, oh, jetzt gibt's auf den Sack.
Ja, da haben
die Leute nicht geguckt. Muss
auch mal sein.
Happens. Das
passiert. Ich bleib mal liegen, vielleicht killen die Leute
noch was, aber ich glaube nicht. Ich meine, da ist ja nur noch
ein Charmy und ein Hyla und ein Bersi
übrig. Die können,
also den, ah, nice, easy RP,
okay. Ich sag doch Bersi und Burst Damage,
Leute, glaub's mir. Wenn ihr
Burst Damage im Nahkampf machen wollt, ey,
die gehen gut durch. Die gehen gut durch
nochmal, die Jungs. Ey, die gehen richtig
gut durch. Jetzt erdet noch ein Infi,
fuck. Und unten kommen noch
mehr.
Der Clary ist noch
tot, lol, nice.
Die Alps kriegen uns aber auch nicht gekillt,
richtig, oder?
Okay, Fahrradpumpe
ist down. Oh nein,
unser Hyla ist rausgelevelt, fuck.
Das ist sad, das ist sad.
Das ist sad,
gell. Aber ich mach noch weiter,
Group ist gut.
Ohne Hyla, äh, ohne Hyla ist es halt schwierig.
So, Mighty Fine, also
gibt's schon mal Stärke. Stärke
können wir gebrauchen, das heben wir mal auf.
Konsti, Konstitution?
Parrystärke?
Das heben wir mal auf, das könnte man gebrauchen.
Ich hoffe, es suchen noch ein paar Leute
Group. Aber noch ein paar Titel,
die wir irgendwie
reinhauen können.
Moment, ich kann,
ich hab nen Titel, den ich gar nicht mehr auswählen
kann, seh ich das richtig? Lul.
Ja.
Den werde ich halt einfach auch so lassen, ja.
Dass jeder sieht, dass ich
Season 1 ein bisschen gespielt hab.
Wo ist Velopumpe? Da ist Velopumpe.
Train.
Battle
Songs.
So, äh, Battle Songs,
hier gibt's neuen Damage Add.
Nice. Aber die Tanks taugen
hier auch, das merkt man.
Die gehen auf die richtigen Targets.
Und ihr seht, wenn ein Bersie
auf nem, äh,
Monster ist, der platzt halt in 2-3 Schlägen.
Grade hier mit der
miesen Ausrüstung, die man beim Leveln hat,
ist es halt echt pog. Leider ohne
Heiler wird das viel schwerer jetzt.
Noch ein,
ein RR, dann
kann ich, glaube ich,
SOS specken. Das werde ich auch machen.
Das ist eines der
wichtigsten
RRs
von einem Skalde.
Ach ja, und warum euch
die Leute auch in Coop mögen, ist Wasser-Buff.
Braucht man nicht so oft, aber wenn man's braucht, braucht man's
einfach. Ohne Wasser-Buff
und, also Wasser-Atem-Buff
und schneller Schwimmen-Buff
bist halt aufgeschmissen.
Würd gern mal
bei mir in
in das Training-Window reingucken,
wie viel RRs ich frei hab.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ist das Spiel mit Adobe Dreamweaver
programmiert? Nein, Flash.
Das Spiel ist, wenn du's genau wissen willst,
Spaß beiseite, das Spiel ist programmiert
in, ähm,
Game...
Biro, oder wie diese Engine hieß, die früher
viele verwendet haben. Das ist die gleiche
Engine, wo, glaube ich, auch
die Elder Scrolls-Engine drauf
basiert. Kann das sein?
War das Elder Scrolls? Ne,
Fallout.
Oh, fuck!
Exhausten, ich fass es net.
Okay, wir haben, wir haben gelitten.
Wir sind dead ohne Heiler.
Wir sind komplett dead ohne Heiler.
Sind's...
Wir sind dead, können wir nix machen.
Keine Chance.
Ohne Heiler bist du verloren.
Gegen ne Voll-Group, gegen mehr, äh, gegen zwei
Gruppen! Es sind zwei Gruppen
auch noch. Da bist
du lost. Boah, alter!
Wie viele Hips?
Ich glaub, Game Biro oder so heißt
die Engine.
Da wurden damals tatsächlich relativ...
Ist das ein Heiler, der hier steht? Nee, Skalde.
Ähm, da wurden damals tatsächlich
relativ viele Games mitgemacht.
Wir bräuchten nen Heiler.
Haben wir nicht
nen Molbeck? Einen Heiler, der
für Groups sucht oder so? Vielleicht...
Hunter...
Healer! Hier!
Ist doch einer.
Guck da!
Ich seh ihn doch da schon rumhüpfen. Nee, das ist ein Skalde.
Die gibt's auch noch!
Alter!
Die hab ich ja vor Ewigkeiten das letzte Mal gesehen.
Okay, gibt manche
Leute, die sind noch krasser drauf wie ich
und spielen das Game durchgängig wahrscheinlich
seit 20 Jahren.
Die gibt's schon ewig, die Jungs
hier vorne. Also, die Gilde.
Und manche Namen kommen ja auch irgendwie bekannt vor.
Da haben wir öfters auf
äh, Dartmoor
als wir noch hier
8 vs 8 für Fechter waren. Oh,
da drüben. Nee, sind Mids.
Siege Giant defeated. Okay, mit
Keep Raid wird nix.
Das sind die maximalen Kreisel, Cry.
Naja, die haben wahrscheinlich schon
10 plus Lebensjahre in der Ork.
Okay, hier sind erstaunlich
viele unterwegs. Guck mal, da eine Gruppe
Mids, da eine Gruppe Mids und wir.
Wenn wir jetzt
schlau sind,
zerren wir die einmalig zusammen
weg, sodass die keinen Bock mehr haben.
Okay, nee, machen wir nicht. Wir machen
jetzt erstmal ein Desert.
Desert Herz.
iPhone 2.
4.
Gibt immer richtig gut Exp. Immer so
ein Drittel Level,
wenn man die Quest abgibt.
Quest.
4 Stück noch.
Okay, da haut der drauf.
Okay, jetzt sollten wir's
haben. 10 von 10.
10 von 10 geschafft.
So, und jetzt
sollten wir hier nicht auf einem Haufen hüpfen.
Weil ich möchte
in den Nordwesten.
Okay, Nordwesten.
Die haben keinen Bock.
Ja, auf. Ich baide
euch. Ich baide euch in die Mids, Leute.
Kommt her. Ich bin alleine.
Ich bin alleine, Leute. Ihr wollt mich
bashen.
Jetzt rennt doch nicht wie die Hühner
hier rum, Mann. Kommt halt
zusammen. Wir müssen echt
aufpassen, dass hier...
Wo ist Velo? Wo ist Velo?
Velo? Velo, wo bist du?
Velo, stellst
den Wasser rum, Mann.
Wo sind die?
Velo, wo bist du?
Velo?
Velo ist dead. Wo ist er denn?
Dahinten. Okay.
Ja, das ist natürlich
ähm...
dead. Oh, lass mich
in Ruhe, Mann. Du flirtest mich nicht,
Kollege. Du flirtest
mich nicht.
Da wird nicht geflirtet.
Flötenchamp
hat heute ausgeflirtet.
So,
dann holen wir mal unseren Shummy ab.
Kurz. Weil ohne
Shummy ist ziemlich doof.
Ohne Shummy
keine Buffs.
Ihr könnt doch einfach alle sprinten.
Sprint.
Tio
hat keinen Bock.
Was macht eigentlich Tio?
Jetzt, wo ich den Namen gerade lese.
Das ist nicht Tio, aber ihr wisst, wen ich meine.
Den, den, den Youtube-Tio.
Der, der
früher auch ab und zu mal Video gemacht hat
mit mir.
Ja, genau, der Tio.
Was macht der eigentlich? Dem habe ich ewig,
wirklich ewig nichts mehr gehört.
So.
Next.
Ja, wir sollten denen hinterher gehen, by the way.
Also.
Lass den mal hinterher, sonst rennen wir wieder alleine rum und kriegen auf den Sack.
Das ist auch doof.
Auf.
Bewegt euch.
So.
Gab es einen ordentlichen
Umhang vielleicht?
Ah.
Energy und Acuity.
Und hier haben wir Quickness und Strength.
Ne, das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall weiter.
Ich bin begeistert. Es sind jede Menge Mids
gerade am Start.
Da können wir doch ein bisschen durchrubbeln durch den
Battleground hier.
Bei der Gelegenheit könnten wir vielleicht noch eine
von den drei Quests fertig machen.
Für noch
ein maximiertes XP
Experience.
Ah, 22.40 schon.
Aha.
Trauen wir uns nochmal daran?
Trauen wir uns nochmal an Deserters ran?
Wäre schon sinnvoll.
Gibt halt gut Exp.
Server geupdatet.
Nice.
Ich habe heute auch vieles gemacht.
Ich habe Kreisel
gegrindet.
Ich finde, das muss man auch
mal erwähnen.
Das ist ja nichts Alltägliches.
Zehn Stunden Kreisel grind.
Okay, wir haben es geschafft.
Ing, ing, ing, ing.
Oh man, lass mich in Ruhe, Alter.
Kakasa, verpiss dich.
Fuck, ich bin gleich down. No.
Oh, wie viele sind denn das da hinten?
Fuck, ey. Okay, die soll... Schlagt halt
auf mir rum. Ist gut. Schlagt auf mir rum.
Ist gut. Schlagt auf mir rum. Nice.
Man sollte halt nicht unbedingt auf Tanks
rumhauen, ne?
Ein Vier-Bolt-Bade? Was ist denn mit euch los?
Okay, ich bin dead.
Fuck, Alter.
Wie viele Hips sind das?
Guck mal hier.
Und das Dumme rumgepilzt ist schon die ganze Zeit.
Das sind... Alter.
Das sind vier Gruppen. Wo kommen die
alle her?
Halber Realm am Start hier im Battleground, Mann.
Aber...
Aber XP gemacht. Ist doch okay.
Gleich Level up. 0,1.
Noch einen Gegner gekillt. Dann
37. Leute, dann sind wir 37.
Dann sind es noch drei Level bis 40.
Das ist jetzt das Ziel, Leute. Da haben wir noch eine Stunde Zeit
für dann. Könnte...
Könnte bisschen knapp werden. Könnte
bisschen knapp werden.
Meins stirbt da keiner von, wenn ich es heute
nicht schaffe auf 40. Aber 40 wäre halt
schon echt nice.
Mal gucken, ob von den Leuten
hier, die ich in meiner Freundesliste habe, irgendjemand
am Start ist.
Ach, gibt doch ein paar.
Die noch spielen. Okay.
Ich glaube,
jetzt müssen wir echt zusammenlaufen, weil
mit einer Fünfer-
Group kannst du halt hier nichts reißen.
Bei vier...
Vier Hip-Gruppen. Alter,
wo kommen die alle her? Was machen
die hier? Gut, es
ist Mittwochabend.
Die haben halt alle nichts besseres zu tun, genauso
wie ich. Sinnloser Kreisel-
Crying, ne?
Spielen wahrscheinlich auch schon den ganzen
Tag. Da
LFGt einer.
Wer LFGt denn da?
Ein Skalde, joa.
Können wir, können wir brauchen.
Ach, haben wir schon invited, sehr gut.
So ein Heiler wäre halt
noch extremely pog.
So.
Wenn wir wieder im RvR-Gebiet sind,
ich verschiebe mal wieder
die Karte, so dass man es
nicht richtig sieht. Man weiß, man weiß ja nie.
Es gibt nicht so viele Streamer
auf YouTube, äh, auf Twitch,
die Darkstream. Vielleicht
streamsniped jemand
Battleground RvR
Ich trau den Leuten ja alles zu.
Sind wir aber auch ein bisschen
ordentliche Menge.
Was sind wir denn hier?
Zwei, drei Gruppen ungefähr.
Da geht was.
Wenn wir die richtigen Targets picken und die schnell
umfallen, geht da was.
Die Mobs hier müssten wir übrigens auch killen.
Aber in normalen Quests haben die Leute irgendwie
keinen Bock drauf hier zu machen.
So, wir haben doch bestimmt noch Tokens.
Hier.
48 Molvik Tokens. Die könnte man
nochmal einreichen.
Was ist da links?
Da links ist Ink.
Die sehen es nicht. Guck mal, die sehen es nicht.
Nice, das wollte ich. Den wollte ich eigentlich auch metzen.
Bade muss
direkt umkippen. Jawohl.
Nice.
Jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, dass nicht noch die nächsten zwei Gruppen
hier reingerusht kommen.
Oh, wir haben das Artefakt aufgehoben.
Ob das so eine gute
Idee ist? Wenn man so ein Artefakt aufhebt,
wird man immer auf der Karte angezeigt. Jeder kann
sehen, wo man gerade ist.
Ah,
guck mal da. Was ist denn da vorne?
Hips und Alps
und alles.
Ja, nice. Lasst euch bashen.
Soll mir recht sein.
Gibt RPs?
Jetzt hat er gesost.
Was für eine RP-Verschwendung, Mann.
Noch mehr, noch mehr.
Ah, sehr schöner Metz. Geht da rein.
Oh, noch mehr.
Noch mehr. Der halbe Realm ist da, Leute.
Der halbe Realm
ist da.
Okay, du bleibst stehen.
Und dieser fucking Dreckspilz, Alter.
Ich hasse diese Dinger.
Ich hasse diese dreckigen
Pilze. Da raste ich immer aus.
Oh, hier.
Guide.
Dead.
Die Alps wurden schon ausgerottet.
Die haben schon keinen Bock mehr.
Die haben schon Rage quittet.
Au.
Schon wieder so ein Kackpilz.
Also, wenn es eins in dem...
Noch eine Gruppe, noch eine Gruppe.
Auf, auf, auf, auf.
Lauft in uns rein, lauft in uns rein.
Jawoll.
Jawoll, jawoll. Schön.
Ich glaube, ich habe sie ein bisschen gebetet.
Ich habe sie ein bisschen gebetet.
Wo ist unser Chammy?
Der könnte mich...
Oh, guter Chammy.
Guter Chammy, guter Chammy.
Oh, wir dürfen nicht so reinrushen, Leute.
Ja, sehr gut. So, so, so. Perfekt.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt
schaffen sie es am Ende noch.
Jawoll, hau mich raus.
Pet, hau mich raus. Dankeschön, dankeschön.
Da sind sie down.
Da kommen die Nächsten schon wieder.
Lull. Mist.
Mist. Ich hatte kein Spell
mehr ready.
Okay, also, was sieht man hier gerade? Du siehst PvP.
Zwischen drei verschiedenen
Fraktionen.
Wir sind die Blauen.
Das waren die Grünen.
Und ab und zu gibt es auch noch ein paar Rote, aber die sind
irgendwie gerade nicht so wirklich
präsent.
Battleground, das ist eigentlich ein
Übungspvp-Gebiet.
Was du auch daran erkennst, dass wir noch
alle Level
37, 38,
40 sind.
Also, wir sind relativ low level.
Und wir schlagen uns einfach die Köppe
ein für XP und
Alps.
Das sind die Roten, die gibt es auch noch.
Aber da sind...
Die sind ein...
Die sind schon wieder weg. Die haben es schon...
Die haben geistig schon komplett abgeschaltet.
Die haben schon komplett
aufgegeben.
Die sind schon durch. Pass auf, ich leech jetzt den Kill.
Pass auf, ich leech jetzt den Kill ab.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, wie ich den Kill ableache gleich.
Ja, nice.
Excellent.
Die haben wir ganz
schön geschreckt, würde ich sagen.
Ein Deserter noch.
Hallo? Jetzt.
Ja.
Also, in Battlegrounds gibt es...
Ist quasi ein Übungs-PVP-Gebiet.
Wo man Mobs killen kann
für XP, Quests machen kann für XP
oder aber
Gegner killen kann für XP.
Und meistens macht man alle drei Sachen.
Sie sind wieder da.
Und wir sind gerade deutlich mehr.
Obwohl wir die ganze Zeit gekillt wurden.
Aber jetzt haben sie sich mal
zusammen gerafft und sind halt mal
zusammen gelaufen und schon funktioniert.
Wir müssen die nicht killen, wir haben das schon fertig.
Warum killen wir Mobs, die wir nicht brauchen?
Weil es geht wahrscheinlich.
Ich bin dabei.
Wir haben gerade einen Tank im Chat, der meckert,
dass er nicht demetzt wird.
Von unseren Klassen hat demetzt.
Ah, da sind sie wieder.
Die Laps sind am Start. Nice.
Okay, also die kriegen gerade
so heftig aufs Maul.
Warum releast er?
Achso, weil er 40 ist.
Einmal nur die Tasten rollen.
Äh, Laps ist eine
umgangssprachliche Dark-Bezeichnung
für Alps.
Für Leute aus Albion, die wir gerade
gekillt haben.
Früher hat man sie Dosen genannt, immer.
Im deutschsprachigen.
Die heißen umgangssprachlich doch
Alps. Ja, aber
irgendwann war Alps zu langweilig,
dann hat man sie Laps genannt.
Was ist die Hexe
davon?
Ich weiß nicht, ich interrupte mal alles.
Das ist ein Ketzer?
Das ist irgendein Caster, der muss jetzt sterben.
Nice.
Level 38.
Ich klau wieder den Kill.
Ich bin so ein Sack, Mann.
Normalerweise überlässt man heiler
Necro-Kills so, weil das die auch mal
einen Deathblow haben.
Zwei Level noch, yep.
Yep, Clock.
Okay, der eine ist schon 40.
Wir werden bald weniger. Oh, was ist denn da um?
Step Nuts.
Da war auch wieder einer super kreativ
bei der Namensgebung.
Und wir sind deutlich
weniger geworden. Eben waren wir noch zwei Gruppen.
So, wir haben eine Stunde noch Zeit.
Für zwei Level.
Okay, schnell, schnell Trinkets abgeben.
Alter, geht mir aus der
Nee, geht mir aus der Sonne, Mann.
Wir haben auch nochmal gut Exp.
30,2, 30,5
Okay. Wollen die jetzt noch Keep Rate
machen? Ich hoffe, die haben
eine Ramme dabei.
Weil Keep gibt nochmal instant
ein Level.
Das wäre schon richtig nice.
Aber ich glaube, dafür sind zu viele Gegner da.
Ich finde Pogs
ist ein super kreativer Name.
Mein Skalder heißt
Pogs und mein
Charmy heißt Pogs.
Und, und meine
meine
Sorg in Alp.
Ratet mal, wie die heißt. Kommt ihr nicht drauf.
Ja, ich sag's euch. Die heißt Pepega.
Ich hab mir, ich hab mir alle Twitch Emotes
gesichert.
Ich hab einen Char, der Pogchamp heißt.
Pogas, Pepega und auf
Midgard Pogs.
Pogs.
Aber, aber
Pogas und
Pogchamp sind auf Level 1. Da hab ich mir einfach nur den Namen
reserviert.
Okay.
So, wir probieren jetzt
irgendwie das, die Festung
einzunehmen. Dazu bräuchte man
eigentlich eine Ramme.
Das dumme ist nur, ich hab keine Ramme
dabei. Und ich hasse
solche Siege-Geschichten.
Oh.
Alter.
Professional Gamer.
Wir haben eine Ramme.
Professionals
am Start hier, Leute. Seht ihr das?
Massive.
Professionelle Spieler.
Richtige Pros.
Aber die Ramme ist kaputt,
oder? Ist die Ramme kaputt?
Äh.
Ist die Ramme kaputt?
Nee. Nee.
Nee.
Okay, wir rammen eine Runde.
Jetzt ist das,
jetzt ist die Tür ratzfatz auf.
Zum Rammen muss man
auf Eden nichts machen.
Im originalen
Game musste man hier so
ein Rammen-Mini-Game spielen.
Es mussten alle Leute im gleichen Rhythmus
die Ramme schwingen, so.
Hört sich jetzt, die Ramme schwingen
hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen schlimmer an, als es ist.
Im gemeinsamen Rhythmus die Ramme schwingen.
Also es ist tatsächlich das gemeint,
man muss im gemeinsamen Rhythmus rammen.
Und das Mini-Game haben sie
abgeschafft auf Eden. Glücklicherweise.
Ich fand das immer richtig nervig.
Da konnte man nie so brain AFK
rammen. Jetzt muss man einfach nur in der Ramme
sitzen, das reicht. Der Einzige, der jetzt
was machen muss, ist der Ramme-Fahrer. Das ist der hinten
rechts. So.
Ram-Champ.
23, 15. Jetzt seht ihr mal,
wie schnell das Tor runtergeht,
wenn hier ordentlich Ram-Champ am Start ist.
Richtig. Oh, shit!
Alter, wir wurden gerade
weirdchamped.
Oh, habt ihr gerade gesehen? Es hat gerade
einer Öl auf die Ramme geschüttet von oben.
Und Öl ist halt fast
ein Instant-Kill.
Wie man gerade gesehen hat.
Während ich das dumme Emote gemacht habe.
Oh, nicht overextenden, nicht overextenden.
Also nicht zu weit
vor rennen, weil wenn man als Tank zu weit vor rennt,
drehen sich einfach fünf Caster auf einmal
um, casten dich an und du bist down.
Und das will man ja nicht.
Und da spricht mir eben Darok Fachjargon
on overextenden.
Könnt ihr irgendwann mal mit glänzen,
wenn ihr das wisst. Wenn ihr auch einen Boomer-Chef
habt, der Darok gespielt hat, der weiß das.
Und da sage ich
overextende in Darok auch nicht zu weit.
Aha.
Diese dreckigen Pilze, Alter.
Ich bash die jetzt.
Das ist, das ist der
wahre MVP hier.
Kein Damage machen, sondern Root-Pilze
killen.
Das ist der wahre MVP-Move gewesen.
Das ist die Frage im
Bewerbungsgespräch. Also sollte ich
mal irgendwann Bewerbungsgespräche durchführen müssen,
was ich nicht hoffe, dann werde ich auch fragen,
ob die Leute nicht zu krass overextenden,
wenn sie MMOs spielen.
Oh, der Siege-Giant kriegt gerade ganz schön
auf den Sack.
Wir müssen, wir müssen den Siege-Giant
irgendwie protecten.
Moment, hier sind zwei Siege-Giants?
Warum
hilft uns der Hip-Siege-Giant?
Ja gut, der ist halt einfach da.
Und macht auch mit.
Und kloppt das Tor.
Gleich gibt es ein Bonus-Level, wenn wir das Keep einnehmen.
Übrigens, das ist der Grund,
warum ihr
nicht mit Donnerkrieger anfangen solltet,
wenn ihr das Spiel startet.
Weil ihr immer eure komischen AE-Plitze
in alles reinmacht,
auch dort, wo es nicht sinnvoll ist.
Wir sollten den Hip-Giant
auf gar keinen Fall killen.
Der soll weiter aufs Tor hüpfen.
Äh, hüpfen, Alter. Weiter aufs Tor schlagen.
Nice.
Jetzt rein.
Was? Ink-Door?
Ja, rein, rein, rein, rein. Alle rein, alle rein, alle rein.
Alle rein zum Lord, alle rein zum Lord.
Rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, Leute.
Ink-Door heißt, Gegner sind am Main-Tor.
Die Fick-Pilze.
Genau, so sieht's aus.
Äh, wo ist der Lord?
Ach, da ist der Lord.
Auf.
Lord muss gebasht werden.
Easy.
39, Leute.
39, 4.
Level 40.
Wir kommen. Easy.
Easy an einem Tag. Solo.
Solo an einem Tag, wohlgemerkt. Solo.
Also mit Solo meine ich,
ohne Premade-Gruppe.
Find ich voll und ganz okay.
An einem Tag Level 40.
Der Lord ist das, wo Lady
oder Lord, äh, NPC-Name
drinsteht.
Obviously, Leute.
Weiß man doch.
Weiß Cringe, wer das
nicht weiß.
Äh, wo sind denn die Gegner?
Ach, hier oben.
Da war einer.
Äh, wait a minute. Ich habe, ich checke
das Layout gerade nicht. Wo geht's hier
nochmal hoch? Ah, hier.
Überfordert.
Okay, ich glaube, es sind alle dead.
Alle deadge.
Okay.
Sechs Bubbles
noch, wie man das nennt.
Bis 40.
Eats.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal die Interface-Elemente
erklären. Habe ich, glaube ich, noch gar nicht gemacht.
Hier. Gruppenfenster.
Sieht man.
Ausdauer.
Mana seiner Teammates.
Kompass, Himmelsrichtung.
Karte.
Ähm, meine eigene
Leben. Mana Endu.
Target, was ich angeklickt hab.
Quick Pass.
Buffleiste.
Questdings, die man nicht braucht. Und hier unten Packet-Loss-Anzeige
und Uhrzeit und sowas.
Hast du auch schon mal moderne Sandbox-MMOs gespielt?
Ähm.
Gibt es
da so viele?
An was denkst du zum Beispiel?
Hier sind alle Level 40.
Ich nicht. Ich brauche noch
ein halbes Level.
Okay, das letzte halbe Level machen
wir ganz
DF-Raid.
Oh, fuck. Leute.
Ich brauche beim DF-Raid mit.
Dazu brauche ich aber Level 40.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Okay, das kriegen wir das schnell hin.
Ich brauche noch
Okay, ich brauche 3,6 Bubble.
DF
könnte auch 35 sein.
Wir machen den DF-Raid noch. Gibt es. Gibt kostenloses
Level und ich brauche die EXP E.
BG
Join
Centrix. Okay.
Ich checke kurz
DF ab, ob DF
Level 39 ist.
Wenn es Level 39 ist, dann
mache ich mit. Ich glaube aber, es ist
40 und damit habe ich gelitten.
Den DF-Raid würde ich noch gerne mitmachen.
Ähm. Und ich bin
planlos.
Ich könnte auch schnell Quests hier machen.
Warte mal. Wo ist ein DF in Midgard?
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Äh. Ja. Es war so.
Du spielst Albion.
Das habe ich auch schon so ein bisschen
aus der Entfernung beobachtet.
Bisher.
Vom Ingame Chat Blur.
Weil da halt Zeug geschrieben wird.
Wo die Leute auch nicht wissen, dass er...
Ah. Fuck. Darkness Falls ist 40
bis 50.
Oh. Mir fehlt nicht mehr viel.
Okay. Vielleicht. Okay. Chat
Gehe. Habe ich noch irgendeine
Quest fertig?
Nein. Nein.
Drei
Desserte.
Drei Desserte
brauche ich noch.
Und vier. Okay.
Vielleicht klappt das.
Ähm.
Nochmal ins BG. Battle Crowns.
Also ich muss. Ich muss irgendwie
Level 40 werden in 10 Minuten.
Dass ich in dem DF Raid mit kann.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich das packe.
Weil das wäre dann gleich
Instant Level 41.
Äh. Dark
ist auch sehr PvP fokussiert.
Okay.
Ähm. Ich brauche...
Scheiß drauf.
Also ich...
Ich brauche Frösche.
Äh. Okay. Ich habe Realm Rank 2
gereacht.
Alles klar. Nice.
Ich habe gerade XP bekommen für...
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher was.
Ähm.
Sind wir das mit dem Relikt?
Oder sind Gegner das mit dem Relikt?
Bin da gerade...
Etwas...
Am...
Unschlüssig. Wenn das Gegner sind
bin ich jetzt im Arsch.
Moment. Ich muss mal kurz gucken was das ist.
Sehen wir gleich hier vorne.
Was ist das? Sind das Gegner?
Alter!
Das sind 30!
Oh ne. Moment. Moment. Moment. Das sind auch Midis dabei.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Können wir da reinleachen irgendwie?
Können wir da irgendwie reinleachen von der Seite?
Irgendwas ableachen?
Ne. Gell?
Fuck.
Alter. Das ist das halbe Realm am Start.
Wird nix mit den 10 Minuten Level 40.
Dark ist class based.
Class based.
Allerdings ziemlich gut.
Du hast 3 unterschiedliche Reiche.
Die alle unterschiedliche Klassen haben.
Komplett unterschiedlich.
Es gibt eine Klasse weil einem Addon nix mehr eingefallen ist.
Aber im Prinzip hat jedes Reich so 13, 14 glaube ich über den Daumen gepeilt Klassen.
Und jeder anders als die anderen.
Also schon sehr nice.
Das gehört den Alps.
Schnell die Cats killen.
Ich probier mal irgendwie die Quest hinzukriegen.
Vielleicht krieg ich noch Level 40.
Bis in 5 Minuten oder so.
Aber das glaub ich nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Ich hab auch noch nicht mal Buffs.
Mir fehlen die Buffs.
Okay eine Quest krieg ich aber noch hin.
Komm her.
Timber Cat komm her.
Wenn nicht mach ich morgen die F-Raid mit.
Laufen die Admins von dem Realm gerade Schweiß über die Stirn weil er selber frequentiert ist?
Naja ein bisschen.
Die neue Season ist gerade erst gestartet.
Das heißt jetzt ist viel los.
Und...
Oh less than one minute.
Keine Chance auf die F-Raid.
Okay machen wir vielleicht hier hinten noch schnell die Quest fertig.
Und dann ist gut.
Dann machen wir jetzt entspannt Level 40.
E.G. Leaf.
Machen wir jetzt noch entspannt Level 40.
Wir haben noch 50 Minuten Zeit.
Das ist richtig.
Bestes PvP-Game ever.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass es für die Admins Business as usual ist.
Es sind aktuell ungefähr 3000 Leute so über den Daumen gepeilt am Start.
Am Wochenende auch mal ein bisschen mehr.
Das hält der Server schon aus.
Also man muss sagen das läuft erstaunlich gut das Zeug.
Im Endeffekt ist es ja...
quasi nachgebauter Server Code.
Den offiziellen Server Code für das Spiel hat ja keiner.
Mir fehlen halt nur die Buffs.
Man benutzt den offiziellen Client.
Also das Game.
Und das Server Code ist halt nachgebaut.
Kurz Ragen.
Wird der geheilt?
Alter, der wird geheilt.
Der Mob wird geheilt.
Ich raste aus.
Was ist das?
Der fucking...
Alter, was ist das?
Wollen die mich verarschen?
Die sind sicher untereinander.
Was soll denn das?
Seit wann sind...
Seit wann ist PvM gedulds erlaubt, dass sie sich untereinander heilen?
Ist das Subscription based wie WoW?
Live Server? Ja.
Das hier Eden ist komplett Free-to-Play.
Gar kein Ding.
Eden ist... kann jeder spielen.
Der Bock hat.
Kostet nix.
Ja gut, es gab Camelot Unchained.
Was mittlerweile fast schon Scam ist.
Wobei ich halt nicht unbedingt Scam nennen will,
weil ich davon ausgehe,
dass der nicht von Anfang an
die Leute scammen wollte
und jetzt es einfach nicht mehr auf die Reihe kriegt
und wahrscheinlich Angst hat vor Klagen und allem.
Aber Camelot Unchained wird halt nix mehr.
Oh!
Was zum...
Leute, mein Game geht gerade kaputt.
MonkaS!
Mein Game ist kaputt.
Da fehlt die Wand.
Aber so Grafikfehler...
gibt's manchmal.
Das hatte Darok schon immer.
Hier, Schamane.
Schämen!
Wollt ihr mal schnell killen?
Wie viel brauch ich denn davon noch?
Brauch ich gar nicht.
Was muss ich denn hier killen?
Molvik?
Moment, da unten pullt was.
Da unten hat was ins Wasser gepullt, oder?
Seh ich das richtig?
Hat der was ins Wasser gepullt?
Das sind...
Das ist der Boss!
Okay, nice.
Ist das Hardcore PvP?
Wie man's nimmt,
ehrlich gesagt war Darok das einzige Game,
wo auch Casuals
PvP gespielt haben.
Was aber daran liegt,
dass das halt so, wie soll man sagen,
so Realm-basiert ist und dann halt viele,
auch viele Casuals, die hauptsächlich
Monster gebasht haben und so
gesagt haben, ja okay,
dann geh ich halt auch mal ins PvP,
wenn irgendwas wichtiges ist.
Ist ja eigentlich ganz cool.
Ansonsten hast du ja Leute, die hassen PvP,
haben da Angst vor oder so, keine Ahnung.
Also nicht zwangsläufig, aber es gibt ja
Leute, die haben wirklich Angst vor PvP,
deswegen spielen ja auch viele, sagen wir mal,
keine Multiplayer-Shooter oder sowas.
Das ist denen nix.
Das ist denen zu competitive und anstrengend.
Kann ich auch verstehen, gibt da
auch Tage, da hab ich da keinen Bock drauf.
Trinken? Ja, du hast recht.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht voll PvP-Loot.
Das nicht.
Dann hätte ich da wahrscheinlich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Voll PvP-Loot.
Ich bin ja schon ein paar Mal gestorben und wieder...
Ah, guck mal, ich hab noch Molvik-Trinkets.
Aber uns gehört das Keep.
Uns gehört das Keep.
Ja, das bringt ja nix. So, ich guck jetzt mal kurz,
ob ich vielleicht die...
ob ich das hinbekomme, die Bäume
zu killen. Aber ich seh hier oben schon
irgendwelche Mid-Hips anrücken.
Also wenn ich...
Eigentlich sollte ich's haben. Guck mal da.
Sway am Start.
Oh, warte mal, hier war was.
Hier war was. Hier war ein Schleicher.
Habt ihr da auch gesehen gerade?
Sind hier Gegner, oder?
Oh shit! Alter, da unten ist das
halbe Realm.
Vielleicht krieg ich noch ein paar Bäume kaputt.
Für Quest
und dann hab ich Level 40 erreicht.
Alter. Alter, Baum!
Okay, drei Bäume
noch. Drei Bäume noch bashen.
Als hätten wir heute noch nicht
genug Bäume gebasht, ja?
Wir haben gefühlt vorhin das halbe BG
nur Bäume gekillt.
Was sind Hips? Das sind die Grünen.
Aus Hibernia.
Oh nein! Stelzer!
Da sind sie!
Sie haben mich weggestelzt von
nach vorne. Guckt, da waren sie.
Ich bin... Ich gehöre zu den Blauen.
Ich gehöre zu Midgard. Zu den Wikingern.
So.
Alter, 0,5
Mann. Hätten die mir nicht
einfach diesen dummen Baum killen
lassen können und dann wäre ich jetzt 40
gut. Ist... Okay.
Komm, ich lauf nochmal mit denen ne Runde mit.
Ist gut.
Wir killen jetzt noch ein paar Gegner und dann geh ich auf.
Mach Auto-Follow. Mach ich auch.
Guck, Auto-Follow hab ich an.
Stick
nennt sich das in Darug. Stick. Mein Game...
Leute, ich bin zu lang online. Mein Game
kackt ab. Ich bin
10 Stunden, knapp 10 Stunden online.
Das macht's... Das geht nicht mehr.
Ist vorbei.
Das verliert
Teile vom Level.
Ja, Memory... Wobei, Memory... Komische Memory
Leaks, wenn man hinläuft, sind sie wieder da.
Guck mal, es gibt jetzt nen Timer,
dass man nicht unsinnig viele Potions
nacheinander trinken kann.
Aber mit 40 kann ich dann auch endlich Mana
Potions trinken und
dann ist... dann ist gut.
So. Leute, ich will Bäume
bashen. Please. Lasst mich
Bäume bashen. Ich will einfach nur
Bäume bashen. Aber ihr wollt
keine Bäume bashen, oder?
Nein, die wollen keine Bäume bashen.
Die wollen... wollen Hips bashen.
Na gut.
Da. Da sind sie. Das ist mein Level
40, da vorne.
Das ist mein Level 40.
Rein da.
Gachibas.
Jetzt rennen die weg.
Ihr seid mein Level 40.
Bam.
Level 40.
Wir haben das Tagesziel geschafft, Leute.
So.
Ich versuche jetzt noch die Alps zu killen, da vorne.
Oh, da sind ja noch einige. Oh, da kommen ja immer
noch mehr. Oh.
Oh, oh.
Die Mids haben sich verpisst.
Da unten sind noch Alps am Start.
Der denkt, man sieht ihn nicht.
Wie auch immer. Alter, der
ist aber mal sehr optimistisch, der Dude, oder?
Der ist mal
sehr optimistisch, Alter, dass ich ihn
jetzt sehe.
Guck mal, hier.
Dreckspilze. Dreckspilze,
Alter. Wenn ich diesen
Kack schon sehe,
dreh ich durch.
Da dreh ich durch.
Okay.
Noch mehr Ink?
Oder was? Nee.
Was ist hier heute los?
Kreiselcrime of Doom ist los.
Zehn Stunden Stream.
Übrigens,
schön, dass so viele Leute am Start sind.
Ich meine, für normalen Stream
sind das jetzt ja nicht super viele.
Aber es sind immer so im Durchschnitt so 60
die 90, teilweise sogar 100 Leute da gewesen.
Und da muss ich halt sagen,
mega nice. Ultra, ultra
pogu.
Okay, Deserter mach ich noch mit.
Da gibt's nämlich
Exp.
Ink, Ink, Ink, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Da waren welche am Start.
Pass mal auf, pass auf.
Habt ihr die Gegner gesehen? Da waren sie doch eben.
Ja. Ich hab mich gleich mal
verpisst.
Ich wollte nicht gebasht werden.
Es gibt richtig guter P gerade.
Okay,
der Pilztyp, der muss direkt
zerstört werden. Und, passt auf,
was bei Anis ganz wichtig ist.
Erstmal
T-Baggen.
Dass das nicht hier zu freundlicher Atmosphäre wird.
So, Kackpilz
muss gleich zerstört werden. Jawoll.
Ich bleib jetzt so lange
im BG, bis sie komplett
Rage quitten.
Bis sie komplett
Rage quittet sind.
Und ich kille Pilze.
Pilze ist das Schlimmste
in diesem Game.
Vor allem Tangler-Pilze.
Okay, Deserters killen, schnell.
So, drei Deserters
noch, gibt nochmal gut Exp.
Und dann noch die Bäume. Dann mach ich die Bäume
noch. Und dann krieg ich nochmal richtig gut Exp.
Weil wenn ich sterbe, ist halt das Problem.
Wenn ich sterbe,
komm ich halt aus dem BG raus und
dann...
kann ich nicht mehr abgeben.
Ja, den da noch.
Siehste, killt den halt einfach.
Okay, und jetzt? Und jetzt kill ich noch
die Bäume und dann bin ich happy.
Dann hab ich alles, was man machen kann
in diesem BG gemacht.
Ja, die Grafik, ich mein...
stimmt schon. Alter, mein Level
entlädt komplett.
Ist komplett, komplett weg.
Komplett deadkill.
Guckt euch das an. Gleich crasht das
Game wahrscheinlich. Ich bin zu lange am Stück.
Guck mal, jetzt lädts noch nicht mal. Ah, jetzt lädts wieder. Okay.
Und jetzt muss ich nur noch heil
heil zum Keep zurückkommen,
dass ich die Quest noch abgeben kann.
Weil ich bin schon Level 40 und Level
40 bedeutet, wenn ich sterbe, werde ich
automatisch aus dem BG raus teleportiert.
Was echt doof wär, wenn ich
die Quest jetzt noch mache.
Okay, zwei Bäume noch, Leute.
Zwei Bäume noch.
Aber das Dumme ist, ich muss
ich muss kurz Mana ranken.
Und wenn hier Stelzer sind,
bashen die mich so hart jetzt, wenn ich hier sitze.
Stream Sniper
Ey, ohne Scheiß, mich würde es
nicht wundern, wenn es sogar in diesem Game
Battle Crown
Übungs PvP Streamer
gäbe. Ich trau
wirklich, ich hab da kein Vertrauen mehr in die Menschheit,
was sowas angeht.
Und dann einfach nur noch hier rüber zum TP,
zum PK,
zum Keep und noch eine Quest abgeben.
Aber selbst wenn ich sterbe, ist nicht
wild, die Deserters Quest kann ich auch im nächsten
abgeben. Ich verliere maximal eine Quest, also
nicht so schlimm. So.
Einen Baum noch, einen Baum noch.
Den mache ich jetzt hier hinten,
dass mich gar keiner mehr sieht, ey.
So richtig am Arsch der Welt
wird der Baum gebasht.
Guck mal, so voll im Gebüsch, da sieht
mich doch keiner, Mann.
Okay, ein Schlag noch, dann ist der Baum
dead. Okay.
Ich hab das übrigens auf Hotkeys, ich weiß auch
nicht, warum ich das klicke.
So, wir können Tokens
Tokens noch abgeben.
Aber ich glaube, uns gehört das
Keep, dann können wir keine, wir probieren das mal.
Einen Schlag noch abzugeben.
Wo sagst du dann, kann man das spielen?
Äh, Eden heißt das.
Ja.
Eden Dark,
da gibt's auch ein How-to,
How-to-Play.
Du musst hier im Prinzip den offiziellen Client runterladen
und dann
den in den Launcher starten,
die patchen dann den offiziellen Client
und verbinden dich mit Eden.
Geht's?
Fuck! Alter!
Das gibt gar keine XP mehr!
Anzeige!
Das gibt keine XP mehr,
wenn man über 40 ist hier drinnen und das abgibt.
Hätte ich einfach mal, habe ich einfach mal
komplett umsonst gemacht.
F. Ich hätte eigentlich
gedacht, dass zumindest noch die Quests,
die man noch hat und abgibt, dass die noch
XP geben. Aber anscheinend
nicht. Dann gehen wir jetzt mal
sterben. Wobei,
warum sollte man sterben? Wir teleportieren
einfach raus.
Aber wie gesagt, Dark
ist echt so ein Ding.
Da wird halt nichts erklärt, so richtig.
Das ist für Einsteiger, glaube ich,
wirklich
etwas Eingewöhnungszeit
erfordernd.
Bis das
in Fleisch und Blut
übergegangen ist.
Okay, wir porten raus.
Leider kann ich die Molvik-Tokens nicht abgeben.
Schade, jetzt hätten wir noch den
DF-Rate mitmachen können, wären wir ein bisschen schneller gewesen.
Na gut, nicht schlimm.
Wir porten mal kurz
in die Hauptstadt.
Und dann muss ich mal kurz
mein Gear durchgucken, ob alles soweit
passt. Wir sollten auch richtig
viele Bounty Points jetzt haben fürs nächste
Gear. Ich bin 2L0.
Gut, ich bin eigentlich
eher 7, also so gut wie eher 7 gewesen.
Ne, wobei 6, 6L8 war ich
glaube ich das letzte Mal. Da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
2000 Bounty Points.
Easy.
So, wir müssen mal zu einem Heiler.
Constitution verloren. Irgendwann.
Wo steht hier ein Heiler rum?
Glaube ich. Irgendwo.
Irgendwo ist hier glaube ich einer.
Oder auch nicht.
Porten wir mal ein.
Dann muss ich noch mal kurz mein Gear checken.
Und dann machen wir morgen
40 bis 50.
40 bis 50 war früher
schwieriger als
1 bis 40.
Aber mittlerweile
geht das ganz gut.
Wo ist denn der Heiler?
Normalerweise steht der da. Da ist er doch, ja.
Okay, mal kurz Gear check.
Gear check machen.
Okay, alles auf meinem Level. Ich brauche auf jeden Fall
neuen Kram.
Dann haben wir neue Sachen
bekommen. 35er Gürtel.
Quickness
Stärke. Constitution
Quickness. Okay, wurscht.
Auch
äh, Leggy?
Wurscht.
Ähm.
Aha.
Ne, die behalte ich.
Brauchen wir nicht. Brauchen wir nicht. 40er
Dings. Melee Weapons.
Okay, das könnte man sich
tatsächlich geben.
Ja, könnte man sich tatsächlich geben. Gar nicht so übel.
Ach, das ist Müll.
Äh, das ist gar nicht mal so
schlecht.
Gucken, ob ich noch capped. Capped Quickness
hab hier nach. Nicht ganz.
Ne, dann.
Ich muss es mit Gear Optimierung
jetzt auch nicht übertreiben. Ja.
Nein. Wir reden hier von Level
Equipment.
Quickness, Dexterity.
Hits.
Ah,
das können wir alles, können wir alles sellen.
Was kann ich mir eigentlich kaufen
von?
Äh.
Ey, ich bin AR6, Mann.
Steht doch immer im Titel.
Okay, Sell.
Bam. So.
Molvik,
Zerstören. Tinderboxen lassen
wir mal da. Molvik Tokens brauchen wir nicht mal.
Äh.
Molvik Hero Necklace brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Trinkets, Molvik.
Tinderbox.
Okay.
Ich würd sagen, wir sind
durch für heute.
Gibt's noch irgendwas? Ich hab noch 20 Minuten Zeit.
Lass mal überlegen. Gibt's noch irgendwas,
was wir
machen können, was mir was für
morgen bringen würde? Ich denke...
Oh nein! Oh nein!
Ich hab meine Tränke mitverkauft.
Das Ding verkauft Tränke,
wenn man Sell All macht.
Oh, was
ein Scheiß, Mann.
Muss ich mir einen neuen Trank kaufen.
Das ist ja räudig, äh.
Nein, nein, da will ich nicht hin.
Ich will... Ah, wo sind denn hier die Teleporter?
Jetzt hab ich meine,
meine Mana und Endo Tränke verkauft.
Fuck. Okay, ich darf auf
jeden Fall nicht Sell All machen. Das muss ich gleich
von der Leiste runterschmeißen.
Sell All. Sell All kommt von der
Leiste runter.
Okay.
Jetzt hab ich wenigstens ein bisschen mehr Geld,
um was kaufen zu können.
90, 80,
100 Charges.
What? Alter.
Marktexplorer? Was los?
Okay.
Ey, what the f... Game!
Please, nicht kaputt gehen. Jetzt noch.
Okay, jetzt geht's.
Alles. Bye.
Yes.
Hat der auch Mana Tränke? Ja, der hat auch
Mana Tränke. Okay. Bye.
Except. Und das Gute
ist, jetzt kann ich auch endlich Mana Tränke
Tranken.
Excellent.
Ich quitte jetzt.
Komm, wir gehen hier noch
laden. Wann der Fabian?
Ey, ich hab ihn noch nicht überredet
bekommen. Vielleicht, vielleicht, wenn er Bock hat
am Wochenende, aber ich glaub's ja nicht.
So, hier haben wir heute Morgen angefangen.
Level 1.
Jetzt sind wir Level 40 und sehen schon richtig
pro aus mit unserer Rüstung.
Es soll auffallen mit seinen komischen
Weep-Gadget-Games. Ja, also ich auch so.
Ordentliche Games spielen.
Jetzt ist das Game gecrashed.
Weil ich... Das hat im Ladebildschirm
Probleme, weil man Reshade anhat.
Okay, Leute.
Wie lang war ich heute on?
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz checken.
Which Wobblons?
Ich war heute...
Äh, 5 Stunden?
Okay.
Ich war 9 Stunden ungefähr online.
Das ist für
meine Stunden echt viel.
Gibt Leute, die machen das täglich.
Ich
weiß nicht, wie man das täglich aushält.
Aber
für meine Verhältnisse war das schon enorm
viel. Alles klar.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Bisschen was anderes.
Level 40. Pogu.
Wir sehen uns. Morgen
Level 50. Und vielleicht
abends dann ganz normalen
Bastel-Progress-Stream. Mal gucken.
Wir müssen ja auch Advent of Code
weitermachen. Bis denn, Leute.
Wir hören uns. Macht's gut. See you.